and jumps on
um
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
right
we'll start the stream once again
uh i'll reconvene the hearing my
apologies to those who were on the live
stream and and lost it we did have an
issue at our end which we have now uh
rectified thank you for your patience
thanks also
uh mr jonker for your patience and
waiting sorry about that
i've got nothing else to do at work
who needs it i'm over it really
um
yeah thanks thanks for giving me time
people how you going on dears um
i just wrote my submission then
basically i think um
the more people in favor of getting it
done the sooner the better i think we've
procrastinated enough we just need to
get on with it more positive people that
have the attitude then we'll get
something done
um the cost is a cost it's going to cost
the rate pays no matter what
you know um
the bigger the better
do it once do it right
let's get away from the whole
pyramid thing knock it down it's a fire
hazard
terrible idea from the start
waste wasting space
just build something that can we can put
as much stuff in as possible and with
future proof
the rest of the plan
if you look at the city block how they
done it they made everybody buy the
materials at the start so the cost
wouldn't go up we need to be a bit more
proactive and doing stuff like that with
you know what but like i think it was
nobby's article in the express that said
that all the figures get blown out all
the time
we need to start thinking like how
they've done the city block and do that
more often
maybe we've spread ourselves too thin
and we're working on too many things at
once and we need to prioritize
especially with the rise the way the
costs are going like all these figures
we've got now
are obsolete basically week by week the
way prices are going up
being in the building trade it's
shocking like
air quotes will only last for three
three months
and then the obsolete just the way
prices are going so
you know
as a council we need to be looking at
this realistically
and saying all all their figures and
things like this
are a rough guideline we can't you know
i don't think you should be writing them
down telling people because that's when
people get windy and mine because like
oh you've said this and now it's this
and blah blah blah there's some you know
and they're looking at people to shoot
which are you guys basically you're in
the firing line
um
but the reality is it's happening to
everybody from the homeowner to me to
everybody i just think that we need to
just lock it in and do it stop
procrastinating get on with it
um
a museum we've got that little one down
on the corner
like as far as the size of our town go
that's pretty pathetic really i've been
there i thought oh is this that
you know and like
all their visitors
the one at riverton is brilliant i think
i think that's a top class museum for
the size
i think we need to learn from that
um not go along the two papa lines
to papa heat had family that worked
there they hated it
i think it's too too flashy too showy
i'm old school i love just wandering
around museums for hours and looking at
old stuff
you know sort of my era takes me back to
the childhood but um
uh you know to me i think
in that plan we talk about a cultural
center and all that and then we talk
about a museum to me they're two
different things just about
um it's a bit ambiguous and some of it
some of it you talk about infocard some
of you talk about southland
i think um
we need to be a bit clearer in what we
say to the public
that's about all i have to say i just
want you guys to just to get on with it
i mean i don't want to butcher money yet
i think you're doing a great job and
we're actually getting something done
which is good but
you know times money the longer we
procrastinate the more the prices are
going to go through the roof i think we
just need to shorten it up if we can
shorten the time frame and lock it in
and do it i think we need to build that
facility out at tisbury because we've
got so much stuff i mean basically the
museum now is a storage shed we've got
so much stuff in there that we need to
put it somewhere and then bring it to
the museum of the art gallery or
something um
just talk about anderson's park being an
art gallery but like for
accessibility to the public especially
the ones in the wheelchairs and all that
sort of stuff we haven't got the room
there i don't know what you'll do with
it too good just to let go but
um
and so yeah
that's basically my submission
thanks
thanks for the the practicality and
encouragement in it um there was
something in your submission i was quite
curious about
your your suggestions of what could be
in there what's bloody jack
bloody jeff jack i think jackson married
a married chief oh sorry i'm with you
now right yeah they called him bloody
jet because he used the word bloody all
the time from when the english whalers
came in and so he got the name bloody
jack
and so he's one of um
you know
way back in history he's one of the
local identities from the maori point of
view
but like he you know um they took him
off to england and everything he loved
it he loved it but like that's our local
history that people don't know about
thanks it does i missed the nickname i
apologize no that's all that's all good
man
questions councillor crackit and
councillor amundsen thank you councillor
um my question is a bit around you you
mentioned prioritization
and um if you have a look in what we're
consulting on not just the museum
redevelopment but there's also within
the annual plan surrey park rugby park
um
book bluff boat ramp uh anderson house
the water tower yeah lots of different
priorities so what would you see and the
list of things that we've got to get
done what do you see is the top priority
and what would you bump down the list
the top priorities i would
see saw between the water plant because
i mean you know with all this three
water stuff but we need good water and
the museum i think it's you know a bit
of a shame that we don't have a museum i
tell you our size um
anderson's park is just ticking over
you know there's no real plan i don't
know
if there is of what we're actually going
to do with it the bluff boat ramp
maybe you can put a toll on it make the
boaties pay every time they use it i
don't know um
yeah yeah you know it's it's a it's a
part of our society but there's other
boat ramps around if you wanted to use
them
um
oh yeah i forgot i forgot the other ones
you see there they're in here aren't
they
city upgrade oh let's not talk about
that
that one's already very much in training
rugby park i mean
realistically how many games do we have
there
you know like um
if you ask me i'd bowl it you know for
the amount of people we get coming to a
south and rugby game
do we need it
i don't know there's a lot of money
spent upgrading something that's pretty
much well obsolete you look at sky tv
like rugby across new zealand we're not
getting the crowd numbers
you know all their stadiums are used for
other things apart from rugby that's
where we get our numbers from
and for cargo we don't
you know am i hearing that you'd rather
see it as like a multi-purpose facility
so it was used for other things rather
than just rugby
i would like to see it
sold and then build something around the
stadium area so we can bind the car park
and all the facilities around one i mean
south and rugby used surrey park school
as a training ground now
um not so much rugby park
you know there's probably a bit of room
there
wiggle room to move um
but it's like you know like i said car
parking car parking is a big thing
if you can use a facility and then multi
multi-purpose things around it
maybe that's a bit of a cost saver in
the future i i don't know um but it has
to be multi-purpose
you know
rugby's rugby will always be here
southwind will never be the heights of
what once was but i mean
you look at the crowd numbers you know 5
000 on a good night do we need the
stadium
[Laughter]
thank you very much for your submission
and and your nice straightforward
presentation we really appreciate it
thanks i'll let you get back to work
okay guys have a good one thank you
uh i see rochelle's not here as yet but
dawn welcome along oh no she's just
arriving sorry no
we'll give you a chance to get
comfortable
thanks
morning michelle perfect timing
uh if you make sure whoever's speaking
has a microphone right in front of that
would be really welcome and uh feel free
to take your mask off while you're
presenting rochelle we have your uh
written submission on behalf of the
hikukai collective the time is yours
um
um thank you for the opportunity for the
murahiku kai collective to speak to our
written submission on the redevelopment
of te unum museum
so um
just for those who
are unaware or would like to be reminded
the muruhiku kai collective is a
strategic leadership group to help um
build a better local food system in
mudahiku and our goal is
that good kai is
accessible affordable and sustainable
so
the
kind of based on which we
see
it as being important to submit on these
kinds of things in bakayo city council
as
acknowledging the council's
mandate to
you know uphold community wellbeing and
all of its decisions
those
being the cultural social economic and
environmental
well-beings of our community
and
kai or food
intersects with all of these areas of
well-being so it's very very relevant to
all the decisions that council is making
so um
this is dave kennedy one of our chi
collective members dave is the vice
chair of farmers markets new zealand
amber jade brass is um the general
manager of kohakai
and i am a systems innovator for healthy
families invercargill and um help to
facilitate the kai collective so i'll
pass over to amber
children thank you all for your time
today
um
so mihokukai collective we believe we
have a real opportunity here
um with this museum to connect and
engage with tamariki
we've been through food through
throughout the museum
um
local seasonal championed we've got a
beautiful region so why not champion
that
if tamariki are engaged quite often the
whanau will come back to those things
our specific asks uh
we would love to see edible gardens
indoor and outdoor
um
our council did a wonderful job of the
edible gardens um so far so why not uh
continue with that
and telling our local food story um
throughout
the museum as well
and inspiring their action
and that engagement um
and
that knowledge bringing that knowledge
forward for our tamariki yeah
thank you
so kira koto back again wearing another
hat um
so um
the local food story uh we think that
should permeate uh tennoa museum
um i think it was that you have this um
submission rochelle has they've all got
copies of this is that right okay so we
won't repeat that too much and also um
supporting the fact that good kai should
be accessible and affordable and having
the facilities to ensure
that there's areas for
filling water bottles for breastfeeding
and so forth in nutritious foods should
be sold in the cafe
the other point that wasn't included
that we think may have potential is at
the reserve site where the storage
facility is going to be built could also
be
an ideal spot for
growing um
historical plants of value they could be
like
heritage fruit trees or even
formati
medicinal plants or plants used for
different purposes
traditionally would be ideal there so we
think that
historical tanga should be both artifact
and living and that there's a symbiosis
between the two
so
we'd um also like to reignite this
conversation around having a large
edible garden inside of queen's park
this is an idea that has been put
forward in the past
i think it
one of the points in which it came out
was around the discussion about the
chinese garden
and so here's an opportunity to
um see how this can be incorporated into
the design of te unawa museum
and um and physically connected to the
museum
so
also
it's imperative
that the council
uh design a carbon neutral green
facility
there's also an incredible
opportunity in this to
be um
you know build an exemplar and
you know a building that showcases the
very best of technology museums are
about past present and future
um
and
helping us to learn from
from the past in order to
imagine what the future might look like
um
and in terms of community wellbeing
ensuring that there are
facilities infrastructure to support
active transport for both
visitors and
staff that work at the museum so
yes so in essence we are very excited
about the te unua museum redevelopment
and we
urge the council to
use this redevelopment opportunity
to
contribute to
a
local food system that is accessible
affordable and sustainable and to use
opportunities that food presents to
capture
the imaginations of tamariki
local residents and visitors alike
thank you for your submission councillor
crackit
um thank you council ludlow and maudina
guys thank you very much for your
submission this morning um our of
particular interest to me was you
mentioned of heritage fruit trees and
the maori medicinal medicine and the
symbiosis that that could create with
the tisbury storage center
does a facility like that exists in new
zealand that has heritage trees and
bits and pieces like that
the south coast environment centre have
had a project
an open orchards project they've
identified
i think over 80 different varieties of
apple that existed in farm orchards
around southland so there are groups and
and there's seed saver groups as well
that exist but it just makes sense i
think that a more formal approach has
taken to make sure that some of their
more
important
fruit trees historically and perhaps as
i said the kind of maori medicinal
plants and so forth are acknowledged
um
and that would be an ideal place to to
include them if the space is there
okay councillor soper
thanks mr chair uh kiara rochelle
while your submission says you don't
have a preferred option of the three
would it be fair to say that from what
you've said today and from what's in
your submission that you don't see
option one as
the preference
yes that's right so um in actual fact
reflecting on the submission
you know the murahiku collective we um
we discussed it and we
we did kind of say that we weren't and
you know didn't have a preference for
any particular option but then when you
look at what would be necessary to
incorporate our
goals and desires then it's probably the
third option that would need to be
pursued yeah in order to give effect to
our wishes
thank you for that councillor partner
thank you chair uh my my quick question
is to do with the nutritious foods now
the previous museum's cafe served the
most amazing cheese roll known to
mankind
would the cheese roll make the cut on
your nutri nutrition nutritious food
list
okay
i would have thought so if it's
yes and um
but not all cheese rolls are created
equal as you know
um and
and the other thing we would say is if
you look at the
good food road map which the muruhiku
kai collective has used as the basis of
its submission to the long-term plan
it talks about
one of the five kind of ideals and
a good food system is for food to be
culturally appropriate
so um yeah you wouldn't want to take
away those kind of
um those iconic foods thank you i'm not
sure about lolli slice though
i won't ask about lamingtons
reverend cook
one thing i could add if i may that may
be of interest um this is through my
vice chair of
new zealand farmers markets that i've
become aware of this issue around the
country we're struggling to have growers
providing food and most people would
have noticed that in their supermarkets
there's not much local food available
south and used to produce about 80 of
their food needs some decades ago it's
down to 10 percent now so most farms are
actually growing produce and product for
export and very little ends up in in
local
stomachs so
um we would think that by promoting the
kind of things that we've been pushing
for it's actually shifting
people's thinking around the value and
importance of local food
thanks dave try not to jump over me
again
reverend cook
sorry
um
i'm just really mindful
that
what you're asking in in this plan
and hooking on to inua and the storage
facility
is actually the council to go into the
business of growing food
i'm not necessarily opposed to that per
se
but if you look at growing food at
tisbury which is not proximate to where
the park is
that adds
reverend cook we are heading to a
question i am heading to a question
why do you think that it's something
that we should do with ratepayers money
because
most people who come to submit to us are
looking at ways of producing not
increasing the cost
that's a good question
so
in what way would you justify the
the capital investment
and i guess it's like with anything it's
around
seeing the long-term benefits of a
current investment
and
we've done a lot of work
together with the council looking at
looking at edibles and public spaces
and what we have found is that in many
cases there is no
extra cost
involved in substituting edibles for
ornamentals so it's really just about
a redirection
um and
reallocation into different kinds of
plantings
and
in addition there is a lot of funding
being released into this space
um
and so
i believe that there are probably going
to be funding opportunities if the
council
embraces these opportunities yeah
thank you
and thanks to the monahaku kai
collective for your submission
congratulations on your environment
award
last year as well and we appreciate you
coming along to submit to us this
morning
next up the distinction hotel group mr
thompson mr mcsurly welcome along
good morning thank you mr chairman
i thank you for the opportunity to speak
to the distinction hotel
hotel submission this morning
my name is luke mcsarly and i work as a
planner for wsp we assist assisting
distinction hotels
with the new project and with me today
is mr jeffrey thompson from distinction
hotel group
thank you
as the submission has been pre-read our
intention is to provide a quick overview
of the project present some images of
the hotel
and then answer any questions you may
have
i'm not sure where i'm supposed to be
pointing this
oh we can give it a manual nudge along
from here
it'd be great
thank you
okay so this is the master plan that was
attached to the submission
so just give a quick overview of this at
number one we have the conversion of the
menses building
um to 150 guest bed four and a half star
hotel
at number four we have conversion of the
former south and frozen meat building
to residential accommodation
so that's going to function as staff
accommodation for the hotel
at number three we have demolition of
three buildings of local heritage
significance and replacement with a new
hotel car park
at five we have upgrade and adaptive
reuse of a building of local heritage
significance at 18 s street west
and at number seven
we have retention and reuse of a
building of local heritage significance
at 13 street west
as noted in the submission distinction
hotels is currently progressing resource
consent building consent and other
council approvals
so the purpose of coming and talking
today is not to circumvent those
processes in any way
but to hopefully start a conversation
with the council
on how the development connects and
functions with their street west
as you can see by the master plan it's
quite a comprehensive redevelopment
of this part of the cbd
and the only property on east street
west not involved is the railway hotel
which fronts some 11th street there
so if you just click through thank you
so that's the existing menzies building
i'll just quickly run through some
images now and then finish on um
four key points and we'll open it up
it's a 1960s former government
department building and the next image
please is
what distinction groups proposing so
it's basically complete reclaiming
of new facades for the building
an extra story at the roof level
two additional stories to the rear wing
on the crescent
and demolition of some of the existing
uh wings of the building
if you just keep rolling through thanks
so that's the view from the crescent
uh and these are the
elevations that's the view from the
north thank you
west
uh south from the crescent
and the east elevation
um and we're just going to finish on
these uh four points quickly so the new
hotel project will have significant
benefits um in our view for the cbd and
invercargill city
to maximize these benefits we think the
new hotel needs to integrate with their
street west and connect to the cbd
effectively
um i i think you know in our view street
west is badly in need of some changes
and this this is a really good
opportunity
to revitalize that part of town
and also in doing that achieve some
really positive urban design outcomes
and to just to finish distinction hotel
group would like to work with council to
maximize the potential benefits of the
proposal
and i guess the key point here is
distinction doesn't have any ability to
influence the road reserve estate west
that's councils
but they'd like to work with council to
discuss
where that could lead
and we think it's um it's really a
really good opportunity to
make some changes to that part of town
thank you
thanks luke jeff you have obvious
experience with repurposing buildings as
we've seen with the distinction in
dunedin um
to to what extent um
ballpark do you think you're going to
require street works um outside of nest
west
well
in an ideal world you'd want
connectivity from the um the transport
into the hotel so we'll have
like right now we've got eight of the
top inbound tour operators and steward
island we've brought them down they
spent yesterday going around transport
world dig this motorcycle mecca they
come back on wednesday do it again so
we're already out there
marketing um
to the wholesale industry that bring
tourists into invercargill and
so we're pushing like mad to get
tour coaches into invercargill get
tourism into invercargill put another
strength economic bow and i'd like to
ideally see some connectivity from the
hotel back through to the cbd
and we've now got
the railway station being filled up i
managed by the building off gear and he
ended up with the railway station so
there's got to be a lot of people down
that end of
esk street
so it's an opportunity for the cbd
so
you know you're looking at a few hundred
extra people that potentially can wander
around the cbd our itineraries are
trying to be based around two days
um for a lot of these people to actually
give them time to
wander around the town
and hopefully
part with some of their hard-earned cash
so um
that's the ultimate name of it so
um
so we'll start their marketing campaign
the they're over the steward now because
we're trying to leverage that they'll be
back on wednesday we're taking them to
the ascot the langlens and
trying to work in with other local
operators to try and grow the town so
thank you um yeah it's quite important
councillor cricket
thank you councilman ludlow good morning
thank you very much for being here and
thank you for you want to pull that
microphone and please help your proposal
which is really quite substantial and
exciting for the city um my question is
around project prioritization and
timelines
so um obviously we haven't consulted on
anything to do with streetscapes in this
area and you can see we've got quite a
stacked line up there that we need to
address what's your timeline for this uh
proposal and when would you be looking
to require these works
i'm tiger for punishment we've started
selling the rooms from september 23
so um
[Music]
hopefully
if we can get the supply chains to
actually keep up with things that's um
we'd like to think we can be open by the
end but if we aren't um
you know
we'll work around that at the time that
there are other accommodation options in
town and um
it depends on how many people come and
tourism tends to start slowly you'll get
a few start and and then it builds so
um if we're not quite ready then but i'd
like to think we can be so
um
so if we could have something resolved
by then it'd be really nice if we can't
well i will just have to live with what
we've got and i understand that but you
guys don't know what
you know opportunities are out there in
the future we don't tell you
yeah
councillor pottinger thank you chair
uh jeff
um
as a councillor
we have various projects happening and
stuff at the moment and
we're constantly being made aware of
escalating costs in fact
exponentially
so
in your world you see this as a problem
for you because obviously you've just
answered the question this is going to
happen right now
so
um you have no problem with with what
current costs can
you know construction costs supply
you know supply is one thing but uh
you're not deterred
yeah i'm getting old and stupid and i'm
not really worried about the cost it's
about the outcome so for me if it costs
me a lot more than it should and i don't
get a return i don't mind
it's not necessary about
this is not done the normal business
model so
as far as costs and return on costs is
not the number one priority for me
outcome no excellent congratulations
thanks luke handy that you're here um
maybe you can speak to this next
question how long have you allowed for a
regulatory process
well we haven't um darren is a simple
answer to that it's sort of i don't know
how long it'll take we've put our
submissions in we're still a few months
away from getting the architecture and
engineering finished
and
hence september 2023 if it can be
achieved it could be achieved we can't
call hey that's it sort of um
i'll try not get a heart attack between
now and then and run with what happens
thanks luke anything to add there
uh we'll just add that with there's an
application currently for conversion of
the building to visit um
visitor accommodations permitted in the
zone so it's actually an application for
the demolition works and
height extensions over 10 meters
um yeah yep
councillor lewis thank you chief very
quick question jeff can you take your
mask off and can you make sure you're
right under that mic
thank you
suitable staff
resources
in the invercargill linking them with
any plans like sot trainings or
we tend to find that when we start a
hotel up we'll bring staff
key staff and from the other hotels
and that's why um
if you look at the old state building
just past the um the side of the um
menzies building there's a four bedroom
apartment up there the other building
the other heritage building we're
keeping is one bedroom apartment there
and the old menzies oh not the menzies
the old south and frozen meat four-story
tear will end up with 16 um units there
so 16 apartments so
we'll have a reasonable number of staff
accommodation units to be able to bring
the staff and
the staff is real problem present point
on
so
we'll
depending what happens with the
government we'd like to think that we
can bring some
skilled staff and from overseas because
there aren't enough around new zealand
every area that we operate in we
struggle for staff that's worth
wondering thank you so it's yeah yeah
thanks jim thank you sir
council has any further questions
councillor pottinger sorry just one more
question um indonesian you uh won an
award with the design of your car park
there it's quite stunning the itchings
and everything uh the car park you're
proposing is that going to be sort of
centered around our cultural sort of
significance and bits and pieces
well the itch when you say the cultural
significance the etchings that were that
we put on the car park there and the
color and
the grill was done by the architect to
um
sort of link in the weep it was
the era of the building behind us and
when we put that forward to the council
the heritage people um
they really didn't like it it took us
about seven months to get across the
board and then after we built it we
actually won heritage awards from here
to new zealand from the district the
city council in dunedin then they put it
forward as an example what to do in the
heritage precinct so
um i'm not quite sure how it all works
then but the outcome was quite good i
was happy with the final product i find
i was happy with the design with the
final products so we can expect
something similar absolutely
using the same architects
cheers
thank you
thanks jeff thanks luke really
appreciate the submission good luck with
the project and thanks for making the
time available to come along this
morning and thank you thank you finding
the time the opportunity thanks thank
you very much
dawn
this time
good morning meet tournament councillors
this is my first
attempt at this um
wonderful meeting thank you that's right
dawn we've got a safety net you'll be
fine thank you
that's perfect
um
this um
submission that i've put forward with
the design of the
whale the right whale
um i know that you've had material to
read or not
um
i feel it would be something that's
quite striking and
it's something that's totally original
and one of the major things that i
didn't put in this was that
the form
of it
needs to be a flowing form not something
that's made from boxy shapes like i've
seen in other cities in new zealand and
local places
whales have a wonderful outline
and they're so free-moving so i feel
that the look of it needs to have that
character to portray it truly
um
we feel it's important to future proof
in other words prepare for the long term
of the new southern museum and out
gallery
i'm talking about
um
i'll just go on i think it's critical
going forward that we are able to tell
our stories from natural to social
history
and have them safely recorded
natural history entails the land and the
sea of our province
social history meaning our southland
branch of history that emphasizes social
structures and the interaction of
different groups
in our local region
recording certain stories and
encompassing both relics and the modern
creative and history arts and literature
music dance theater
pottery ceramics painting film
in other words our treasured heritage
this will require both air conditioning
and large storage bays
that is
very important
a building represents the lives we have
led and the structure stands as our
stamp and will distinguish southland as
a centre of culture and learning
it is essential
that today's plans are extended with
space
not
adequate for today
the local talents and skills need to be
acknowledged safely preserved and
showcased for
education and pleasure
the architectural designs must encompass
grand plans
for future generations for both local
and international scholars
what we need desperately
is
amazing storage
can you think of airports
i've got a school
i've got three rooms
i haven't got much room left in it and
that's all through my artwork
so if that gives you an idea what i'm
talking about with a museum
scale of work
is major and it all needs to be
at the right temperature
um it needs the right people working
there
and i think that
this city has had a really good time
with our artwork around the city at the
moment we're always happy to support you
and
it's a great opportunity to have people
from overseas come here
as well as new zealanders
it would be a drawcard i feel
thank you
thanks dawn council is open for
questions
reverend cook
thank you mr chair
dawn um
are you aware
that the southern right whale imagery is
already being used in a new build in the
mccable
i'm just asking because you're talking
about it not at all
no i had no idea no no that's fine i
appreciate the effort that you put into
and the imagination and all the rest of
it i'm just sorry that you weren't aware
that that was a particular imagery
that's already been done if it couldn't
be that imagery you're still
wanting something that has flow yes
something that has shaped rather than
yes yes i don't i don't want to see
a wool shed form
with a face on it
does that give you the picture and the
face is all turned
from blocks and
this sort of thing
you know
i could draw you that too
no i appreciate i appreciate the imagery
and i appreciate the effort that you
went into i just thought i needed to
share with you that sorry somebody got
there before can you tell me where it is
um
the new
and um office block oh that's it's the
shape of the southern right whale or the
influence yes
but but thank you because i think
out of all this submissions that
apart from what some of the tamariki
drew this is the only one that's
actually given us an idea of
a potential
uh shape or or a flow so thank you for
that thank you
thank you
thanks for that
councillors any other questions
councillor sopa
thank you mr chair um dawn kira
i also just want to say thank you
because there's been a lot of submitters
have said they would like the pyramid
shape retain but you're probably the
only one who's come up with something
quite so imaginative and meaningful um
and as miss cooks have me in tears
thank you as ms cox said the idea has
has been used by mira hakumurai
and um
and it's going to be brilliant that is
is a great idea um i just wondered
because of some of the things you said
today and in your submission
did you have time to think about the
separate storage building and from what
you said today do you think that that is
a
good idea that we have that separate
storage building the storage building
um
i know there's plans for use of the
concrete tennis courts or something for
for storage
the proposal was that we built a
separate storage building on what is
currently the tisbury reserve
right so it would be a completely
separate storage building that would not
just be for the museum but also for
the invercargill public art gallery and
potentially
other collections to be stored as a
separate storage building you probably
wouldn't want it too far away because
everything would have to be trolled or
covered
you know to get it there like
inside the museums i've been in overseas
they have
on wheels
with big frames
like pipes
that move
everything around and of course the
weight you have to consider people
working
with that as well because
i've got larger frames now and i'm
finding it a bit more tricky and my
frame is now going to deliver to me
so there's little points like that that
need to be taken into consideration
and then you've got to think about how
they're going to move around in the
building as well
yes yeah
not not a bit of doors off
yeah thank you for those comments thank
you
councillors any other questions
if not a thought provoking oh sorry your
worship yes
congratulations on
acknowledging the whale
but
we have had displays of course in the
pyramid
and
um i'm just wondering how you resolve
that rather bloodthirsty era
and
into modern art
is that a challenge it gives me
something to think about tim
thank you
thank you it would be quite interesting
to have something in the interior
wouldn't it
yes thanks for that dawn thank you for
your submission thanks for giving up
time to come along and and be with us
this morning we appreciate it oh it's a
pleasure thank you so much lovely
experience thank you
robin brash
welcome along robin thank you for your
submission
well first of all thank you for letting
me come but
i've never been to a thing like this and
i'm very pleased i came in early to see
what goes on
i take it everybody has read
what i put in
right
and we were talking about the submission
but one before me i'm just gonna change
subject for a second
mentioned a the new hotel block that's
been built or hoping to be built
it wasn't on the submission at all that
i
or the proposal you put up
but it has given me reason to bring
something up
as far as prioritizing in the city of
prison for the councillors
the number one priority i would think
would be making the city safe
we've got
all the cameras out of action are
present
the funny thing our sports project can
have i think about 20 project cameras
working
it'll be on a part of their
uh maintenance program i presume just
like your roads in the city when you get
a pothole you fix it
i'd like to ask the question of why
these potholes which are individual
cameras haven't been fixed
sorry but i know that's way out of order
but i feel it is
justified to ask and get it put up to a
very top priority
safety is paramount
but it just happened i was here and saw
that
you've all read my proposal
uh or proposals or thoughts
which they really are
but one of the things that starts off
with
is will it be used
as it says within 15 years i've been to
the
in invercargill
i've been to the uh museum
about that number of times maybe more
13 of them would be to see the tuatara
in the last couple of weeks
i've been talking about this
and the work where we have smoke over 30
people and various things
and none of them had heard
that the two ataris were being shifted
and then they said well don't build it
that is the feeling out there
and some of them even said why not bring
some geckos in with it
and call it south seas or something
uh the people understand what it is
and
have
all the lizards of new zealand
in there
the kids can go along you can take kids
to a wet day and then they'll see the
rest of all the good things
and the heritage of new zealand
and what have you
and want to go back
i didn't know what te papa was and
wellington and went to it
there were only two things in it
one was a motorbike and the other was a
wee room
and in that wee room you saw the history
of new zealand
sadly lacking a lot of married culture
there wasn't very much of that in it
but an amazing room that made me when i
had some spare time in
wellington go back again
a feature of this
new development
could be
two type of wee rooms
one that does the
beginnings of new zealand how was formed
and go through the people
as races and what have you as they came
to new zealand
and developed themselves
and including what one of the previous
speakers said about the married chief
and
all these things are missing
and the other on the other area you
could have these are only about 20
minute
settings that they have at tiba
you could have one on
people's histories
what they've done in new zealand george
big in his racing cars
uh
the things that have gone on at rugby
park teratonga
the developments have had our original
power stream menopause
and there's lots of things that have
happened in new zealand
and sporting events
that could just be part of it i'm not
against a museum
at all
but i do look at here
on a project i've just looked at
180 million for the city development
block is that roughly the total figure
at present or is that just this council
figure
i'm just asking this as a totalization
it's a guideline total figure total
figure
you realize that you're talking 74
million to build one museum and they can
do build a whole city block
for 180 million where is the costing
on my rates
for me to go to the museum
if you take what i i'm going to pay in
rates according to this piece of paper
there's 75 times of the dollars a visit
for two visits a year
that's if i go on my own
and then we're calling it a name
which i've got nothing against
the maori part of it we'd be talked
i don't even know what that means
after the public if you put that name up
on front and
and tourist uh
booking agency wouldn't know
whereas you put up something like south
seas museum
people would understand
when they get to it
and everything is part of our history
and we want to know it
but not many people that come from
overseas
can understand the maori language or
whatever and i'm not against the mary
language
but we've got to get them through the
door
this is what i'm trying to emphasize
no one will mind paying this
if it will get people through the door
but i guarantee
when the music before the museum was
closed the biggest attraction at the
museum was the tuataras
now build on it
and you'll build on your museum
that's what people know about
throughout new zealand
and right through the shape
i haven't heard a bad comment
apart from us locals about the shape of
it
people say what's that unusual structure
it captures attention
and that's what we want you look down
the street and see this
from a way out
and it's high enough that you could put
a look out
as you're saying
i'm not worried if you rebuilt something
have to rebuild but
don't spend millions on something just
for looks
you've got to it's what you put in it
that matters
and you've got to get people going away
talking about it
and they'll bring the people back
so if lumber cargo wants to do something
do something that people understand
and want
but think of the cost
half of the city nearly half of the city
block
being spent on one building
i do ask
whether that's justified
well that's
roughly all i've got to say thank you mr
brash it's so i've got time for one
question counselor cricket
oh thank you councillor i think i might
have just snuck in just
sorry could you speak up a little bit
sorry um i um wanted to ask you um
whether or not you'd read in the
proposal that
for
the reimagining of the facility the
tuatara
will partially be included not the whole
facility there'll be a purpose-built
facility for tuatara out with the rest
of the animal husbandry but there will
still be
a tuatara enclosure within the proposed
new museum
so
i'm actually showing you i hadn't
realized that yeah
so i thought you might find that
fantastic as good as what's there
and if you want to expand on it
i remember catching geckos
when i was at school
and various things
uh
having a i don't think you let them
catch them but
build on that
people love those tuataras
build on it we've got to get people
through the door
not worried about taking money off them
because the people coming is good for
the province
it's good for the hotels it's good for
everything
but
it gets them through the door how many
people actually go somewhere to go to a
museum
but if the kids know
grandkids and everything throughout new
zealand a bit are looking to see the two
ataris when they come to south indigo
i know it
because i've got rank it
and that's what gets
people through it's got to be used
come on
thank you mr brash thank you for your
submission and the additional points
that you've made this morning following
the earlier submissions that you heard
uh really appreciated
thank you
melvika would you like to
bring chris henderson in please
chris if you could unmute yourself
please
how's that perfect thank you
thank you for your submission chris the
time's yours
sounds like we've got a little bit of
buffering going on there chris you're
dropping out
i had i had it sorted out
i think it's your fault
[Laughter]
nothing wrong with the wi-fi in town
it's one of those challenges i think
from from real wi-fi
does it work
no chris it is it's dropping out very
frequently
i'm trying to hold it like i did last
time right um
you've read my submission it's backed up
now by a late edition the guardian
article which i urge you to read if you
obviously haven't already because i've
just put it in thanks from emily um
so it's low carbon is my emphasis
heritage is my emphasis being um
a child of invercargill remembering the
trams and all the things that we had
that we've now lost
and also being part of historic places
trust for a gazillion years the cost as
mr brash mentioned is um 76 million or
whatever it was 170 million whatever in
rising 70 million in rising um
to me it's a travesty to add more
expense to
the uh rate plasma for capital and also
southland when we can utilize our
heritage buildings and the time darren
um
i don't know if you've got a timeline i
haven't read the articles
the position papers but the timeline
will be to build this new uh storage
facility and all the other things we've
already lost four years
without a museum
and as i said in my submission we've got
a blueprint there we've got our present
um
temporary museum popped into h j
h j h is building it works fine it's a
blueprint for other ones
and um i just want you guys to be a bit
more creative
so um
and the the other thing that keeps
haunting me which i had from smag was
the intent of the indica city council to
be celebrate to have everything
celebrating it's preserved
for preserving its heritage character
and i think this is the bit that's sort
of at the background of all my
involvement with museum and friends of
the museum
and i'd like to
echo mr brash's comment about the
tuatarium you've noticed in my
submission i had
um a laminated timber frame to hold
secure the pyramid and all the users
that i i had for that the territorium of
course was the the key one but an
observatory and a viewing platform and
all the other things that i included in
my my list
um all could be part of that for a
modest sum um six million has been
quoted as making it a safe place for
storage this is the pyramid but if we
add a bit more to that for actually
strengthening and replacing that pillar
and doing other the other bits and
pieces without the weight of additional
storage upstairs and a planetarium it
could be quite a quite a splendid place
and reflect of course russell beck's um
uh love of
stargazing and astronomy as well as
attracting more
children and their families into the
planetarium and the territorium boy what
combination that would be
and of course remembering nobby's
commented about
you just dropped out for a second there
chris
did you move
no there you go you're back
i breathed with jocelyn and nobody both
saying the place net the town if you
painted red or or any other color um
that was a big bit that prompted me to
put that into my um into my submission
but i know darkly that shouldn't be
fifty shades of grey so i really ever
say to that point
that's enough that's meant to be
um and all the other ideas mean we've
got
no you moved again
i breathed again there you go
confess
kid first attracted huge enough
i want the kids
um
center of town and also out to the out
of the pyramid and that these sorts of
things would attract them
right
i think that's about it i've got plenty
of other stuff including how to to make
buildings safe with carbon fiber
techniques and things
but that's for another day because time
i realize is not not on my side nor a
sound
i'm happy to take questions thanks chris
questions counselors
no chris you'll be relieved to know that
we're going to let you breathe
oh great thank you very much for for
joining us and for making your
submission
you're very welcome thank you for the
opportunity darren thank you councillor
thank you
cheers thank you
richard rongan welcome along
take backseat don't mind the trapdoor
have a seat and uh feel free to take
your uh your mask off while you're
presenting as well um
or on it's your choice
um
i was going to
deliver a bilingual um
element but um for sake of time
um
some elements i will still engage
but
will also translate so that
it can be clear for the record what it
is that i'm intending
my own interpretation
in the first instance uh the first
greeting should always go to the all
creator to the um
of us all the one that uh the creator of
all things good
the second and most important
uh is
to the land that we stand upon
because it is
the place that has nurtured us and kept
us well until this day
and
also i'd like to give reference to this
beautiful fatih the foreign of
the administration building city council
and again there's a lot of history that
goes along with this building
the generations of people who have
contributed to
its existence
as i now turn to
think about and
acknowledge the people who have recently
had loss
and i particularly
refer to the events of easter
where there were five
very tragically
taken
deaths or
um two events that took five people from
our community
but i also take this moment to consider
all of the other people that have been
part of the lives of cellphone who have
withdrawn from this mortal coil over a
period of time and i acknowledge some of
the older
people who will have very clear memories
of some of the other councillors
and mayors
and the person
that i had some direct dealings with
quite some time ago
um
mere paul
but again i'll go back to all of the
others that have gone before her and
before us today
as counselors and people that are
present in this room but carmelio of
this organisation um and particularly
those of you sitting around the table
and
for those that are on
um
this wonderful device that allows us to
to also conduct business at a distance
um
uh
i miss you to you as the
the faces of the organization that is
the city council um and
to you darren as uh the monitor for
today but the cheer for today
um
greetings um
clear headley um also as your ceo um
it's it's finally good to see half a
face that i can put a name to and
of course there are the other
councillors that sit around the table
um
um
the other party that i would like to
mention at this point is
the partner of the treaty uh my funeral
representative sees it here at the table
as well
um
now i turn to the people that sit behind
us
and particularly those who are from
cooper's creek who
i stand alongside in respect of
submissions regarding
um that one line entry that i found and
affects the whole lot of
papers
referring to
charges and
costs and all that sort of stuff being
increased over time as part of a long
term plan
i think that's a
without them um i wouldn't be here
actually because
it was really out of uh
recognition of the
combined histories
that exist
in and around coopers creek particularly
um
i totally whanau that lived there
the
early settlers had arrived and
did whatever they did out there
including the whaling and ceiling and
whatever else was part and parcel of the
environs of the time
um
and as part of this uh i think this
whole exercise of us uh addressing the
ongoing
connection
with that little place that community um
is one that i think is
something that i'm quite proud of being
part of the history of that area
so
i'd like to acknowledge these two sides
coming together for us here today
i now turn to the kaupapa really of
this the submission that i put forward
and i i understand from um this
little exercise that this is their
opportunity to address some of the
issues that
uh
still remain unresolved which is really
the
the crux of the meta um
by the same token i i
had to have a look at our
at the documentation and when i looked
at
um
the
crest
and i found the latin
underneath
that
basically translates to
the benefit of the community
now as part of the community and i'm
referring to
the ratepayers and others
the costs that are being incurred
currently for everybody
primarily due to the changing world that
we live in and particularly the covert
effect
and
with the war again
um
the war in europe um
there are impacts that are being felt
across the community
so
this idea of being faced with additional
charges
over and above
what i understood was custom and
practice
with the relationship with
licensed occupy
holders at cooper's creek and
the council
but again there are other people that
will be speaking to that as well
i've referred to
the coat of arms but then i also
acknowledge the importance of something
as simple as the
vision statement of the council
aroha
our city
with heart
now for me
the importance of aroha as part of that
statement is that it outlines very much
the intent
of engagements that we are
into today
but also in
engagements that have happened
previously
it is about
having compassion
respect and understanding of each
other's position
being benevolent to some extent and
caring kind hearted those are the the
words that i
have as key
but it doesn't feel like that
was the
way that things have
played out in the in respect of the
charges that have already been put to
the
leaseholders or the
licensed occupied payers into this creek
so that is why today i stand before you
and uh
make this submission
um
and i'll leave it at this
um and i would like to finish with the a
little
a little gift that's been given to us
all um by a band from dunedin 660.
be a little
and how does it go
my maunga mana is my mona
aroha is the moana
whanau is my waka
so the mana that you hold as counselors
is really important for it to be
delivered
but by the same token
and the pepe talks about that ocean of
love
compassion care and concern for each
other
in all of the dealings that we are
having with one another as either
ratepayers or others that are engaging
with the
uh council in whatever format
and on that note
i won't sing it to you i'll just leave
you with that
[Music]
photo
richard thank you for your corridor um
and and very articulate presentation i
was kind of looking forward to a bit of
a wire to there i thought well i think
we could wind up with one that we could
all share a bit later on perhaps
um councillors it's open for questions
reverend cook
um i better leave mr chair to respond
please so richard
richards
i just
for those of you who don't know i know
richard quite well and i've known him a
long time
i want to acknowledge that he
acknowledged the very heavy grief that
was amongst our community at easter
and i especially want to acknowledge the
fact that you counted to five
it's been a real mama for me
that the death of chad was overlooked in
the death of the others i don't diminish
the ideas i just want and i'm grateful
that you did acknowledge that so i thank
you for that i thank you for the fact
that you have acknowledged all of us
and that you have used
ariel
to garnish and um to enhance your
cordero to us this morning so thank you
mr chair for the leave to respond to
richard i is most appropriate that we do
so and thank you for your vocado for
those who have gone before us including
me paul who i do remember quite well um
but to remind us that
we are rooted in the past and what we're
discussing today is for the future but
we have to take that past with us to
construct that future
so thank you for that
richard can you remind me
where in a process
uh the residents of cooper's creek are
at because i know that you took your
concerns to the ombudsman so is that
still a working train
i guess to a great extent that's going
to depend very much on
how things progress
i believe that it's still unresolved
um and that there is still
a way forward and uh
i'm sure that if we were to um
well i put my dutch hat on or my clogs
on now um if i were to ask the question
about
how much this whole exercise has cost us
as ratepayers
i would be
i wouldn't be too shocked at what
might
be reported but at the end of the day a
lot of this
this
backwards and forwards could have been
resolved quite easily by having a sit
down around a table and perhaps having
some pay and perhaps sharing a bit of
hospitality with one another
as opposed to going down the path of
the ombudsman and and and legal
but again we all have to have that
understanding of where each other stands
so
that's perhaps not
something that we need to enter into at
this point
thanks for an answer to your question um
it's still unresolved thank you
councillors any other questions
counselor partner look it's it's it's a
really a matter of clarity i asked
before this meeting uh of our in-house
legal advisor michael morris if there
were
any legal things happening at the moment
between the residents and council and in
the sense that it would be heading
towards a
tribunal or a court just in case
obviously we didn't want to prejudice
the happenings of that court now is is
there something legal happening you just
mentioned the word legal so i mentioned
the word legal because um i understand
there's been a legal opinion and from
what you're saying there has been a
legal opinion um on behalf of the
council and that's
okay it's completely understandable it's
justifier is the way where it right
no no that's fine no questions answered
it's just an opinion now that's fine
thank you
yep
any other questions
if not thank you very much for your
submission richard namahinui
uh gila thank you for coming along this
morning um as part of the tikanga um i
will sing you a quick waiata and i will
keep it short and i know uh many of you
will know that the word so please join
in
[Music]
roberts and kerry
hello before i start my submission i'd
just like to clarify we were supposed to
have a meeting with the council um we'd
already had a meeting with them on the
11th of april and we're supposed to have
a follow-up meeting early may but they
have postponed it to the 25th of may
in regard to michael morris in legal
opinion the council aren't prepared to
share their legal opinion with us
we've asked for it twice through our
lawyer and
through the lgo ima twice
but
for some reason
they're choosing not to be transparent
with the legal opinion so i'd just like
to clarify that before i start
right on behalf of all the residents at
cooper's creek we wish to object to the
22
23 proposed increase in rental fees for
crib sites at sandy point to maine as
detailed in your letter dated 5th of
april the residents at cooper's creek
are currently disputing the 60 rental
increase imposed on us in 2122 fees
and charges and to date this has not
been resolved please refer letter
attachment detailing our reasons for
disputing the 2122 increase which i
attached with the submission
note the second last paragraph of the
letter details how the oki street
section only rates decreased to 306.26
our rentals increased from 815 dollars
to 1350. we were forced to pay this out
of fear that our licences would not be
renewed and to avoid occurring bad debt
the council was repeatedly requested to
place the rental invoices on hold while
under dispute but refused to do so
the average age of the licence holders
at cooper's creek is approximately 70
the oldest being a 93 year old widow who
is bob's mother
and most are on limited incomes for 75
of licence holder it is their home and
only asset
for the last 20-plus years our rentals
have increased in line with the icc
rates as detailed in clause 4 of the icc
memorandum of understanding in regards
to the village of keepers creek also
attached
it is important to note that we have
never received individual notification
or consultation regarding any increase
in our rentals for any year until your
letter dated 5th of april 22.
that leads us to believe that none of
the previous increases were valid we do
not believe that a single line on page
37 and the long-term plan under fees and
charges without any amount showing
represents reasonable or fair
consultation
and that was the line that i've cut
and posted and this year
it's even worse because there's two
lines with no figures could you just
pass
down to half the side
so in the 22-23 um annual plan
we have got one line
that's showing 2122 market appraisal per
square meter and 22-23 market appraisal
per square meter we don't even know the
amount
like for all we know that could decrease
and
i looked up the meaning word
consultation
and
this morning on google the action or
process of formally consulting or
discussing discussing
for example they improve standards in
consultation with consumer
representatives
we've had no discussion or consultation
we get one line in the plan until this
year
and 1350 is not the total cost we pay we
pay approximately 500 a year to take
household rubbish to the dump we pay 300
a year to empty our septic tanks so
we're actually paying over 2 000 where
we are
the rigid licensed occupied terms
actually devalue our properties there is
no security banks won't loan on them in
fact the sale of one of the properties
fell through recently after a lawyer
advised the purchaser not to proceed
after reading the terms in the licensed
occupy
that's actually costing people money
the licensed occupied terms change
without notice or consultation all of
the clauses in the past that have
favored the leasi have been removed and
more restrictive measures put in their
place
that is why the mou was introduced to
make it fair for both parties we are not
asking for favors only to be treated
fairly
we will never have good electricity to
our homes which is fine by us
and we have chosen to live off the grid
but by the same token you cannot value
land that will never have electricity or
services at the same rate as land that
do have those beaches was which is
exactly what has happened
the valuation is flawed and the areas
that we have been compared to i.e okie
street and maui and stewart island are
all freehold so it is not comparing
apples with apples
i emailed all of you on the 5th of
october and made you aware of their
situation and only nobby clark replied i
did approach alan arnold um
um in person
so apart from alan i would like each of
you to tell me why you didn't consider a
60 rental increase worth addressing
can we start with you leslie no you
can't
you may ask rhetorical questions but
you're not here to ask questions of us
you're here to make a submission and we
can ask questions of you i'm sorry
that's the process right
why have we had another market appraisal
undertaken within two years of the last
one infocard valuations are done every
three years what does that cost the rate
payer
if the valuation goes down do the
rentals fall
okie street section valuations went up
but the rates decreased
the the owners there get to appreciate
the capital gains with increases of
freehold property
we are guardians of the area we are in
we love living out there
we phoned the police regarding fires
firearms helped lost people rescued
people at sea
you've taken the ranger away from the
area and removed the house
so there is no security
thank you rob anything
you'd like to add no no i'm good
counselors it's open for questions
have you noticed any increase
in vandalism and things since the houses
the ranger have been
removed absolutely and to the area like
four-wheel driving
yeah the area looks terrible the grass
has been left to go long and it's quite
unkempt do you think it was probably
it's actually since that that looks
noticeably since the ranger and the
house has gone well i know that the
range the last ranger did a really good
job and he was a hard worker and he was
like rescuing people stuck at the beach
and things i'm not sure that that was
part of his role but
i know that he was only to if we rang he
was only too prepared to come and help
at all as of
the day and night
and lockheed was there working every day
all day and doing cleaning up and
where the town rangers now do two laps
two laps a day one in the morning on the
afternoon just basically your lap
and they might pick up some loose
rubbish but they're not really caring
for the area just observing and looking
to see if there's any issues
then they must report back to the parks
and action from there
and also a lot of the areas like the
park recreation areas have been locked
no one people can't get access to them
now i don't know that's because people
were doing wheelies in them and so they
just locked them
but i believe you've actually got to
ring and get permission to actually go
on to the areas
like all of them
are always locked up you can't go into
the bay years ago people used to go
there
yeah
they slot the gate so now we can plan a
weekend like most people if they want to
go for a barbecue they'd shoot out and
just do it on the day you can't do that
you've got to pre-plan and indicators
actually wales bay has been planned out
in shrubs now it's not even a picnic
area we'll just close that area we're
just closing the areas up i don't know
why it's just to stop the mowing
the cost
but from where it used to be years ago
it was a family orientated reserve that
for the people
it's being locked up for some reason
thanks questions counselor partner thank
you chair look i'm i've read extensively
the mou
um
now what year was that mate it's got
1992 it was gazetted but
is that the year
of the emma the 1992 the area was
gazetted as a reserve so the mou the
draft of this mou was done mr what mr
bill what wrote it and he said that he
thought it would be about 1990 1990 this
one okay but the council can't find a
copy of it
right on their records okay we have no
copy apparent you've got the copy i
supply you cancel
from
the correspondence we've had they want
to find a sealed signed copy dated
and up to date they refuse
acknowledgment of it
because they can't and and this copy
belongs to one of them it's been issued
all of us have got it right you should
buy the council without lesser stock you
buy okay so then some an added to the
lease yes and the lease is dated when
you first take it yeah so that's just to
add okay who's the favorite to release
when we sign a date the license to
occupy
the licensed occupies have changed from
leases
to license to occupy
they've changed over the years and i
don't think any one of us have got the
same licensed occupy
right the mou was 1990 thank you
around that that's when bill what
thought it was when he wrote it okay
thanks
for our history just one more question
the licensed occupy that you have now
and you used to have at least before
the least before have a like a term on
it so you mentioned before that you've
got no equity in your properties banks
weren't alone against them
did
well has there been a time when you
actually had lease like a 10-year lease
or a 15-year lease which actually would
give the properties there are 21-year
leases out at the properties out on the
way to the beach i think it's something
perhaps
yeah but i don't think cooper's creek
have ever had 21-year leases i think
it's always been new to you they were
sorry they were leases and they've been
changed to license to occupy annual
annually annual yeah
thank you for the mium
[Music]
a permanent writer of renewal right yeah
because back in 90 i think we've had a
similar situation with the rates
increase right from the low hundreds to
400 i believe
but we've got numerous emails to clear
the licensing of any krebs site shall be
granted an annual license to occupy with
a permanent right of renewal provided
all the conditions of the license to
occupy continue to be met and item four
when the license or does grant to the
licensee a renewal of this annual
license on its renewal the license fee
and any rates imposed by the invoca city
council on the property shall be subject
to review the total of any rates imposed
and the licence fee together shall not
exceed the current licence fee in the
first year and any increases in future
years shall not exceed the percentage
rate increase from vocabulary
right
councilor i've just had a message that
um some councillors are hard to hear
because you're not using the microphone
um no that's fine thank you very much so
that's the original
document
that was issued with the license to
occupy
right how long ago
started back to 1990
thank you any further questions
councillors
if not we know the matter is in train we
appreciate the concerns that that you're
raising and for also coming along to
address us this morning thank you for
that sorry i couldn't allow you to ask
the questions but there's a process that
we have to go through
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to come and submit
um obviously the area was a lot covered
in our general submission um and i will
only have a couple of points just to add
here
um
i discovered looking on the icc site
that you have a policy called
significance and engagement policy which
was effective from the 9th of june last
year
and it references back to the local
government act of 2002
which has principles of consultation
and those principles of consultation are
that persons who have views on any
matter that their local authority is
undertaking should have reasonable
opportunity to present those views
in a manner that and format that is
appropriate and
preferences that suits the needs of the
people who want to actually
make a submission
and the view should be received by the
local authority with an open mind
and given due consideration
and persons who prevent present views
should have access to a clear record or
description of the relevant decisions
made by the local authority and
explanatory material related to
decisions
now we've and i've you have my
submission i have been a licensee since
204
and our rates did increase as we
mentioned along generally with the
council's rates over the city
until last year
and that was based on a valuation a
desktop valuation that was made
by a valuer who valued our properties at
freehold rates
and that was in 2020
and so the council and its workers and
officers set on that
with no
liaison with cooper's creek
residence it passed through with the
covert lockdown and
the one little line in last year's
annual plan as per cleared had these
instruction that we should be charged
market rates
which we have through a lot of the
emails that have come backwards and
forwards under the freedom information
act
we
obviously did not present last year to
the annual plan
because it was an unnamed no value just
market rates
things were ticking over there was no
correspondence with the council at all
that
we'll get a 60 increase
we have this year
been advised that we could come and we
could do this process
but
if you can see the blue on this little
letter that we all received
there's a a website there
which has 95 characters
including one underscore
which is lost in the underlining of the
website address
and that was to be our axis
or we could go to let's talk icc but of
course we all tried that or a number of
us did
foolishly because you missed the
underscore
and the council could make it easier for
people to come and actually have
an impact and know what's going on by
just applying for a tiny url and you get
something with eight digits
and then you might get a little bit more
proper feedback but that was a letter i
appreciate that we were notified and
we're here
there's a lot of angst of course because
the new plan that you are looking at
today is is for it to be market
increased again
we're still under dispute
we have had advice from the ombudsman
he said to be declaring everything and
to be
doing as much as we can to come to an
agreement
i'm not sure if your counselors are
aware of
of some of the difficulty that it's been
to actually speak with your officers
and as richard said
we could have sat down and been over a
cup of tea talking through issues and in
fact some of the documents that we
received from you
say
back in
1991 that's why my memory serves me
that there should have been a group set
up to liaise with cooper's creek
residents
it was
seconded by falmer buck i think proposed
by someone else
and that was to do with
the establishment of the memorandum of
understanding
and that kind of conversation has not
happened
until we get to this
wildly extravagant 60 increase
so i would just ask perhaps that we
could have an opportunity rather than us
heading down and
through the law
that she would give us
some time actually just to be able to
have a conversation around a cup of tea
um
excuse me for my glasses back on
um
cooper's creek
historical village
is 3.5 hectares
out of the whole domain area of two
point
sorry 2217
hectares
it's a historical site we all value it
we appreciate it we love it
it was there before invercargill
for 20 years or more
supplied the city
it's a historic place
we do our best to look after it
we look after the animals
get rid of vermin
get rid of wild plants
especially we're a service to the people
with the first place they come
and i'm open to any questions thank you
christine
uh sir to bracey there's this concern
around the consultative process
absolutely um and also the process for
valuation if i've picked up correctly
you're saying that the comparison with
uh the likes of omari is different
because those uh freehold yes you are in
the land the count you know it's public
land it's
how can how can it be valued at a
freehold rate thank you
councillors any questions
if not your concerns have been heard um
do i have any more minutes
you do
i'd just like to bring up
something that was written to
the executive leadership team in
december 2020
which gave the impression that
cooper's creek has only recently been
permanently occupied
permanent occupancy has gone back
50 years or more
since the ranger was
publicly noted
and it's and all of that occupation has
been acquiesced by the council
through its offices
people have been encouraged to build and
have had
them inspected by the council
past test
it's not a new thing
thank you thank you thank you very much
for taking the time to come along and
submit we appreciate that
thank you
brian and ken
so
kia ora everyone thank you for the
opportunity to
come and address you today
um please feel free to have a seat if
you're more comfortable i'd like to
stand just too absolutely same a bit and
then i'll sit down thank you i'll just
say that's all right thank you yes
uh i'd like to start by quoting from um
an email an internal email here at icc
which begins with
an icc admin person
stating that they were keen to
understand exactly what the lease and
management plan state
and what are our obligation for cooper's
creek can anyone please provide these to
me
the response to that from
another icc
management person
was that these are non-conforming
buildings as noted in the sandy point
management plan
we have tried to phase them out in the
past but have met with both public and
political opposition to the same
they pay very little in terms of rental
however
in recent years claire hadley has
requested a larger increase in annual
rent and we have made some significant
increases
i think that it would be fair to say
um that at times
there has been
an historical tension between
the council and the icc
um
sorry the icc and the
inhabitants at coopers creek and i just
referred to you
some
newspaper headlines over the years so
august 1990
sandy point plans come under fire
september 1990 new policy for sandy
point cribs
may 1991 council backs down on crib
rentals
and february 2013 council backs down on
cribs policy
and
to a
more recent
2022
is
not the time for larger rate increases
so
at this point i would just like to read
our submission to you you've probably
all got a copy in front of you a little
bit of background we have owned number
one cooper's creek since 2006
it is a special and unique place and we
spend as much time there as possible
we do not own the land our home is built
on and no services are provided to us
we use the public road to access our
property we pay an annual license to
occupy fee
the cost of which has historically
recognised the absence of services
the fee normally incurs a small annual
increase
last year the license to occupy fee
increased by 60 percent
from 815 dollars to 1
300
this was a massive increase which we
were not informed of
nor were we invited to take part in any
discussion
or give feedback to council prior to the
60
increase being imposed on us
we were informed our crib was to come
into line with market rates on advice to
the council
based on a desktop valuation of our
property by property valuer
we ask how is it possible to compare our
crib fees to freehold rates and rentals
on properties
that have some or all of the usual urban
services
i.e water electricity electricity
rubbish sewage
transport roading footpaths street
lighting etc etc
we felt pressure to pay the huge
increased fee or fear the possibility of
being ordered from our crib by the
council
we do not agree to a further increase at
this time we are in the process of
challenging the fee increase for the 21
22 period and believe a further increase
at this stage would be unfair and
unjustified
until such times as outstanding matters
are resolved regarding crib fees
we also have very strong concerns
regarding the rigid conditions
of our licence to occupy
and i'll just give you two of what i
consider to be rather draconian
pieces of that licence to occupy
one is that the licensee shall have no
right to a review a renewal of this
license
and that's when the council has
acquiesced over 40 years to people
living at cooper's creek
and the other is that the failure to
comply with the rules and regulations
entitles the license or i.e the council
to terminate the license with one
month's notice and any buildings will
forfeit to the license or
and there are several other parts of the
license that are along that same vein
so that's that's about what i want to
say
right um yeah just finishing off what
kev said the status that we're um
living under is really a third world
status
i don't think anywhere else in new
zealand people that rent properties are
under the tenancy tribunal and got a lot
of protection
um we've got nothing so that's why we've
got to fight hard for our case
just want to clarify one thing there too
um just with the rate increases and i'll
just go back to some of you know in
figures so like um
in 2018
it went up one percent
2019 went up 2
five 2025 in 2021 60
we have got no problems
of that mirroring what the rate creases
have been in the cargo and that's what
has happened with our increases all the
time and we have not got a problem with
that whatsoever everyone's quite happy
with that but when this this major
increase comes in
with a very
fluid
way of doing it
it's based on um i believe one hectare
is why where they get the evaluation
from and like it's been sent by other
speakers
it's based on freehold ground if you put
a house on a freehold or
any building on a freehold section you
move that
house or building onto a license to
occupy and the valuation of that falls
dramatically
so
we have got as far as people living
there to try to get capital gain there's
none
there's none whatsoever
and also
i just noticed with the process
that we've been going through in
consultation i've noticed we've been
dealing with a number of people that
have come
in out of the area into southland
um
i'd like to request them you know
when you're making decisions please take
into consideration our history our
culture our heritage because that all
applies to cooper's creek like other
places like cozy dock
blue cliffs measly beach
barriers are part of our culture
and people want them to stay there
i just want to clarify to ellen just
with the um
you said about um
damage done out at cooper's correct war
not so much cooper's creek
in the sandy point area with um
i'll define them as
non-conforming um four-wheel drives
but now a lot of it's done at 12 o'clock
at night we can't do anything about it
whatsoever the whole area out there has
been ripped up particularly last winter
just to note
there used to be a ranger out there
the range is gone the house has gone
only about 400 meters from wherever
ranger's house is
this the soccer field car park got
absolutely ripped up you know it's like
one of our previous speakers said when
we had uh
a ranger out there living there
we could bring them anytime even when
they're off duty they would deal with
matter
it's a lot harder to do that now
we um it is a concern we can't do
anything at 12 o'clock at night when
there's several cars
doing this type of damage but it's like
other um speakers have said
i think the people
that involved cooper's creek are picked
by the creep to be there
yeah we take care of
the area
rubbish is picked up but like said
there's been several fires put out
there's one local resident he has
trapped over 500
rats rabbits you name it cats have been
lost here we didn't bring them there
they're getting
dropped or breeding out there in the
area
so we do play a part as a community out
there and what we do
i think that's very important to take
that into consideration
um
i think that's about all because a lot
of it's been covered by other speakers
anyway so
thanking you for your time thank you
we're almost at time councillor pardon
to you a question yeah yeah thank you
look the um
fees and charges are coming to us in
june for deliberation okay
um that's in the annual plan my question
is regarding the mou
do you think this current mou that was
drawn up that 1990 is fit for purpose or
would you like it more relevant
some of the languages i think it's okay
i think it's a question uh not a
question something needs to be um
ratified here
kef read out two points here before um i
don't know if you can remember them um
about the license to occupy we used to
be able to it was just rolled over from
year to year
but people want to leave their wholesale
in place and get out
type of thing and that comes
what happens with those type of
properties is often people have bought
it they may be a distance away they find
they can't go to their property and
spend much time there and it only lands
up a few times a year so we'll end up
selling them and
this is something with putting this in
the office isn't the newest the latest
license to occupy it wasn't in the
previous ones so that's a separate
document the licensed operation i just
answer your question
for me councillor pottinger um
i think the memorandum of understanding
has been historically a document that
recognises our obligations to the
council as people that live in the area
and the council's rules and regulations
about that
i personally would be very open to
sitting down with counsellors and
drawing up a new memorandum of
understanding but one that recognised us
as a community
some of us have been there for years and
years and as richard said
maori have occupied that that place for
hundreds of years so there's always been
people at cooper's creek
and
as i referred right at the beginning
there's at times been an uneasy tension
between council and residents personally
i would like to see something robust and
solid
that supports us continuing to live
there
um and recognises
just and fair rules about that
thank you
thank you
any further questions
if not thank you for taking the time to
come along and speak to your submission
we do appreciate it thank you for the
opportunity yes thank you very much
thank you
councillors i've been advised that one
of the other
coopers creek submitters wishes to speak
um
but i also note that we're scheduled for
a break
some time ago and in the interests of uh
comfort
i'm gonna adjourn for um 15 minutes and
we because we had um
uh one submit a drop off at the end we
can we can add the other resident
um
so we're looking to accommodate you um
but it won't be straight away when we
come back it'll be just towards the end
there aren't too many other submitters
to go
thanks our counselors we are adjourned
we will reconvene our
extraordinary performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting as we
continue to hear submissions on
our annual plan uh next submitter is sue
smith
coming up and take a seat sir
feel free to uh take your mask off while
you're submitting
it gets a bit foggy
sorry i was expecting to stand
uh if you're more comfortable soon you
can
good morning sir tim almir ceo and city
councillors i appreciate the time to be
able to speak
in my submission annual plan
the proposed rates increase of point
seven eight percent nearly eight percent
is unacceptable unsustainable and
totally unnervous unrealistic
in this current economic climate of
nearly eight percent inflation and
rising fuel costs to those of us in the
real world on a single income solution a
lot more efficient management of finance
time and resources
and staff focus to fix what is necessary
and urgent not what isn't i just like to
expand on that
reality check when receiving 360 000 a
year or you have two to three incomes
per household
there is no consideration for those of
us living in the real world working hard
on a single minimum wage
through no fault of our own with the
cost of living
as mentioned also up nearly eight
percent
single parents pensioners young families
are really struggling
there
is no bought coffees dinners or
discretionary spending in my budget
last year's rate increase of 160 dollars
was hard enough
it is unacceptable and not affordable to
hit the rate payer again
solution
cut back costs and rain and spending
to survive in the real world this is a
way of life i must do
i challenge the icc to do likewise
prioritise what is urgent important with
infrastructure
number one streetscape save two to three
million why develop beyond kelvin street
where there are car parks when you want
it to be pedestrian friendly
communications team for the size of
invercargill
five would be
would do instead of nine or ten why are
we paying for communication specialists
to come in plus all the consultants
legal opinions and chairmans of numerous
committees
how can the civic administration
building go from 14 million to 28
million in such a short period of time
why would you upgrade now
when
when there is a supply shortage
resulting in a 20 plus increase for all
the materials that are needed
steel is up 40
in itself
why would you upgrade when you don't
know what the future of the city
councils are in new zealand
in southland it could go from three to
one
city council
accountability to the right payer
instead of punishing them with ongoing
costs would be appreciated
how
icc has got reserves and cash
investments 50 mil and local banks 37
million properties example don street
reserves and vacant land you don't need
if these 20 to 25 properties were fast
tracked to be sold icc could well afford
a zero increase to the rate payer
which given the current economic climate
and inflation rate
is a more rational and realistic option
why can't i and others afford to keep
our own homes that we have worked so
hard for when icc have enough assets to
cover their costs
the rate increase will push up rentals
which are already unaffordable
does the icc
need more homeless people in
invercargill
thank you
thank you sue
councillors it's open for questions
so if the rate of inflation is currently
at around eight percent and the proposed
rate increase on average
um
just a little bit below that
if if
your suggestion is we should try and
not
match with the rate of inflation what
services do you think council could
cut
or reduce
no my answer to that is not reducing
essential services but using the assets
you have
as i spoke of you have more than enough
to cover that cost without
it being passed on to the ratepayer
so of the reserves assets that you
referred to in in your spoken submission
do you understand that a high proportion
of those reserves are committed to
specific purposes
what proportion
well what
okay what proportion are you are you
talking about sorry the questions are
one way um but i will say that
councillor soper led
three four years ago a review of all the
reserves to make sure that there weren't
funds uh being stored unnecessarily
that couldn't be put to use so um
some of the reserves are for properties
for example or
reserves set aside to cover off
depreciation uh which is an accounting
requirement so that's that's where
uh a substantial amount of them sit
however that's that's getting beyond me
asking a question that wasn't
councillor soper
thank you mr chair um
mr smith i'm just interested a previous
submitter
referred to the rates rebate scheme not
being well known
um in rel in light of your submission do
you think the rates rebate scheme is
well enough advertised
to
the people of invercargill
possibly but still it's just a it's a
once a year reduction
so if you're paying quarterly it's one
quarter you still have to pay the other
three
so for many of us
it's still a struggle
to do that on any rates increase
my understanding is it was spread across
the appetite rates bill
yeah
well that's not how it works
other questions counsellors
if not so thank you very much for first
of all taking the time to to to make
your submission but also for um
for coming along and and sitting in
front of council to present it we
appreciate that it's not an easy thing
to do and it's a
kind of fierce theater
so thank you very much for that
i appreciate that thank you oh just in
reference to your question i'd just like
to say with
um reserves
that i'm sure that there can be
or
i'd be interested to
know more detail about the 20 to 25
properties that could be fast tracked
and sold to keep rates
increased down
um i think we went through a process
that started that last week from memory
so it is underway thank you
now a rather unique situation uh
councillor clark on behalf of the
invercargill ratepayers advocacy group
um thank you for sitting there through
this morning and uh we hand over to you
now for your presentation
thank you chair um
just for those who don't know i'm chair
of the local repairs group
we've already put in a quite a lengthy
submission
so i won't read through that but it's
not appropriate
but just to reflect that there are four
parts to our submission
one is our view on how
the city council can
fund its rate increases beyond the four
percent that are four cars nine months
ago in the long term plan so that extra
3.7
two how rate increases impact on the
volume in our community and you heard
sue and others have talked about that as
well
and with the inflation the impacts that
we've got just more recently
that that group of vulnerability has
increased
thirdly the impacts of compounding rates
and so
four percent this year doesn't mean four
percent next year it means four on four
and then there's a reflection of mary's
story which is really
a reflection of personal reflection on
how hard it is for some people so i'll
take those as being read
our group is not um wanting to comment
on the museum in the long term plan as
such other than to say that we
support the views of others that have
spoken today around the need to display
tuatara and the retaining of the pyramid
shape
our view is that the
um
um the museum inappropriately dominated
the annual plan
uh
exercise
um and some of the information in there
is clearly not accurate
um
so we just put that to aside our main
concern is the
uh increase of proposed increase of 7.7
which is in effect roughly about two and
a half million dollars extra required
over above the four percent forecast
earlier in the year
in early march uh this year icc gave an
undertaking to have an open workshop to
identify what levers were available to
reduce the
expenditures for the forthcoming year or
to increase the income for that period
or to do both
that workshop has not occurred yet
rate powers are
fed up with rate increases that seem to
occur
as the
first option
in this exercise without acknowledging
that council has looked at alternative
options that are available to them
those options should routinely include
use of cash reserves and i heard the
comments by the chair about the reserves
and i'll just reflect that the advice
that i've been given
by the current finance group manager and
the previous one is that those caf
reserves are not significantly locked in
they are available to us
increasing borrowing is another option
sale of property assets
sale of surplus parks and reserve land
reducing expenditures especially around
three waters renewals and around
personnel costs delay or reduced project
scopes as an option and i have one of
them talk about the production and stage
two of streetscapes which we
which we support
or alternatively run an unbalanced
budget
which for for those zooming in or
listening today an unbalanced budget
means that you start off with an income
stream
which is less than what you're
forecasting your
expenditure to be
and in light of that i just draw members
um
attention to section 100 of the local
government act which talks about
the need to have a balanced budget but
then in subset and section 2
does allow for councils to run an
unbalanced budget so long as they meet
one of five criteria and i would see
that we would do that
the advice that we got back from local
government new zealand and from mike
reed who is the principal policy advisor
local government new zealand is that
it's not uncommon for councils to
successfully resolve to run an
unbalanced budget
and that what that does is it it doesn't
get into forecasting of what the cost
would be
and and what the
income would be it allows an unbalanced
badger allows council to work through
the year and see whether it can
make savings as it works its way through
one of the issues i guess that we come
up against
and these
constant increases to rates is the issue
of what projects are costing us which is
not our routine business it's not
talking about cutting services but it's
the projects that impact into annual
plans and
and into long-term plans it's been the
observation of our group the council
staff often present forecasts costs for
projects to elect the members who then
support those projects
then within a short period of time
those costs tend to escalate anywhere
between 50 and 200 percent
so that by by our group there is an
unacceptable way to commit rate payers
rates and needs more appropriate
governance
since the beginning of this term in 2019
our group has monitored
this issue on 10 projects
and that doesn't include anderson house
because we don't have the final costs
um
for that project but we've monitored and
what
the uh invocable central london which is
the big mall that's going up
we've watched streetscape stages one and
two the brakes home upgrade the civic
administration
uh building upgrade the projection for
the water tower
rugby park
66 d street demolition the lower s
street sale
the invocable central limited cultural
narrative and the bluff boat ramp
so in that period of two and a half
years the original forecasted costs
have escalated by an eye-watering
78.3
million dollars
and i just don't know how we run a
business um
with those sort of escalating costs
and so that undermines the confidence
of ratepayers
that they're getting value
for their bucks when they either approve
or accept
uh long-term plans and then accept
annual plans within that
so it's our view
that council should not go beyond the
four percent a rate increase that it's
uh originally had in the long term plan
which came into effect just a short
period ago in fact nine months ago
we believe that the extra
3.7 percent
should be dealt with internally by
council
not by way or rate increase
and our preference is for an unbalanced
budget to operate
so that council staff can
work their way through the year
the extra money that's required the 2.5
would only be required in month 12 which
is june next year when technically we
could run out of money and would have to
subsidise any shortfall
that's the impact of that unbalanced
budget
the other way of course
in our view is to call back stage two of
streetscape and i think you'd see the
previous speaker talk to that
our viewers that um
that when we have escalating costs
sometimes we have to cut out cloth
accordingly
i struggle i guess with the stage 2
development for the streetscape that
goes
beyond
kelvin street on what we'd refer to the
east side
of estuary
we
that extension has cost us millions of
dollars
and for a project that's emphasized by
having
pedestrian
focus i can't see why we would develop a
street that has two large
um car parks in it because by nature
they develop cars into the area
so there are our two preferences um
we recommend to council that they
stick within the four percent
and find other ways to manage the other
areas and our last reflection is that
if you go into any of the media at the
moment you'll see the massive increases
that are coming through
through food bills
fuel bills power bills and increasing
rents
and what started off
six to nine months ago with people on
fixed incomes people on single incomes
people on
tempe work
or casual work with the one suffering
we've now got a significant amount of
people in the working middle class that
are also struggling with this and we
don't believe that we should add
any more to inflationary costs than what
we forecast to do nine months ago
so thank you for that
thanks nobby can i ask if the advocacy
group if your preference is for that
unbalanced budget
what do you see as is the option for the
following year
yep can talk to that
um it's been my observation on our
group's observation
that councils are often quite um
i shouldn't say lacks but i they tend to
be quite generous in their forecasting
of an annual budget
and most years we run at a a surplus not
always some it's often just a hundred
thousand or two but in some periods it's
been a couple million dollars
and so um
the risk of running an unbalanced budget
i guess is that if you run short
you um have to top it up i guess
in the 12th month and so that would have
to come out of one of those investment
accounts
which sometimes is referred to as a
reserve account that doesn't affect the
following year
if we if we put a balanced budget in now
and we put in the full 7.7
the chances are realistically that at
the end of the year we'll be taking some
of that money
um that could be surplus and we could be
putting it into reserves again because
that's where reserves have come from
they've come from services over a long
period of time
and so i think the alternative to that
is to run an unbalanced budget which
means that we see how things go during
the year and make some decisions as we
get to months 9 10 11 and 12. thank you
councillor partner
thank you chair thanks nobody for that
look
page four of the annual plan
document states
[Music]
we've got an increase in
capital this is for the forecast and the
ltp 22-23
the forecast for capital expenditure was
45.4 million that is now forecast for
that year
72.6 million the forecast for
operational expenditure
110.9
now forecast at 115.9
now
my question to you knobi is that do you
think
after one year the current long-term
plan
is now not relevant
and it's actually too ambitious
and instead of
applying effectively band-aids
like short-term rates increases for this
annual plan
should we actually be revisiting the big
picture
of the ltp and that the actual current
model of the ltp is not affordable
moving forward it's just it's it's like
i mean you look at those increases i've
just shown you now
um
do you think we need to start again
i think truly we do
and for two reasons um one is the
escalating cost that i referred to 78.35
million up in two and a half years and
it continues to grow i don't have any
confidence that where we're at at the
moment will be the end product
so we need to we need to go back to
square one the other issue is we've got
a significant amount of um
i guess um structural work to go on
and so that structure would be around
the storage facility and the museum
itself and as much as i've been a very
very strong advocate for getting it done
quickly the downside of it is um it's
becoming more unaffordable and that's
not through
apathy on our behalf brad olsen
yesterday in the zone five six things
said
the lack of
manpower in the construction industry is
going to mean a lot of councils will not
be able to get their long-term plan work
done
because people are not going to exit out
of auckland where there's a lot of work
going on to come to invercarb just to
build a building and then go back and so
i think the landscape has significantly
changed in the last
18 months for us and i do think we need
to revisit and we need to recalculate
the true cost of some of these and if
that's the case we will push some things
out i think even just about every
submitter you've heard today has said
the number one priority of the museum
and if the cost is that we subsequently
don't do a whole lot of other stuff
um
so be it my personal preference is
we are
too far into the block to do any
changing there
brent's home is actually the number one
priority for me because it's the sole
source of water for the city so we can't
afford to not do the upgrade there
and if you went to a museum at some
later stage that would be fine the other
projects unfortunately just need to
drift away
so yeah i agree with the position you
have there
thanks nobody thank you
councillors any other questions we're
almost at time
councillor cracker um thank you um
councillor ludlow just a question to
nobby about um the revisitation of the
ltp and your plan as you've just stated
do you think that that would be possible
within the current time frames that we
have to be working to
probably not
um
and and i guess
and the alternative is that we go ahead
with what we're currently into
um
and we'll end up as we work through the
long-term plan defaulting on some things
that we would like to get done
for argument's sake
just to give you an example we've got a
very very tight frame tight time frame
on the museum storage area at tisbury i
don't think we'll get there we won't get
there from changing the reserve criteria
and so that will stall off
the museum
and even if we do get things
done from the regulatory position i
think we won't get the manpower in the
city to physically do that building it
will delay out so by nature i think
our aspirations under the long term plan
um
will get pushed out we'll end up with
delayed um
time frames i think it was really
interesting that i heard
jeff thompson say this morning the
response to rangi um
he said it's not about the money i'll
just get it done as quickly as i can and
sometimes that doesn't sound all that
professional but i think if you've got a
priority you're stepping away through
and you don't step through those
projects as quickly as you can
so be it
so ultimately focus counselor clerk
would be on reprioritization
i think we've got the priorities right
in the long term plan i just don't think
that we'll be able to deliver them on
time
and i think that's something we need to
acknowledge because otherwise we'll be
criticized including from our group that
here's another long-term plan that
council doesn't deliver a long time
i don't think it's i don't think it's
available to your funding i think that
it's availability
of the resources construction resources
yeah
brad olson was quite clear about that
yesterday
everybody's struggling all the councils
have got work they'd like to do but they
physically can't get the companies to do
it yeah
thanks councillors thanks nobby we
appreciate the submission from the
rappos advocacy group
uh councillors that brings us on
to the submission from
kate and alan hayes
all right
oh my
well i didn't expect such a full
audience today i'm a little bit taken
aback by it
um first of all i must say forgive the
english accent
um i'm two-thirds kiwi and only
one-third english who came here in 1971
but i can't get rid of the accent
you must also forgive some of the
nerdish references i give to etymology
this morning too
it's all to do with
culture i've heard a lot this morning
even though just been sitting there for
a short time about money so i can
sympathize with that but i also
sympathize with culture as well
and rightly or wrongly new zealand has
two cultures and both should be
equal
i say that because i can remember um
a few years ago during maori language
week they were interviewing people about
its validity
and everybody was agreeing it was a good
idea um and uh i was
too and then they
uh interviewed a woman in auckland who
said oh i'm english i've got no culture
i thought you stupid woman
um
but you know we do have culture if you
look at the scottish culture around the
city the name of the streets and so on
it's all something to be proud of as
well
i mentioned about being
nerdish about etymology
one of the words i'm going to refer to
is icon
and that comes from a greek word acone a
konos a neuter noun
don't i sound like a nerd
um
which means
literally just image
and
the other word
that uh i mentioned is just the word
museum
language is culture
why is it a museum
well the greek gods youth
um had uh
nine affairs shall we say with memosy
and their children
uh were the muses and they were the
inspiration for
song dance memory poetry and so on so
that's why we call a museum a museum
but referring back to that
icon
image
if you think about it
anyone who lives here and even the
people who come down here visiting like
our children who
two of whom have gone to auckland silly
people um
you close your eyes and what do you
think of if you've been here for some
time
i think of the the water tower
it's an icon
it's part of the heritage
i think of the war memorials
i think the bank corner i think of the
neoclassical architecture down d street
and along esk street and so on
i also think of the pictures
the side of the kelvin hotel a very
modern picture very nice right lovely
the scottish hall over the road with the
night and his sword and so on
culture
more recently
um i'm thinking of the
umbrella
um
that has been moved and the facade on
esque street
and
the way saint john's has been preserved
in the new building it's all part of
keeping
culture i think
the
most important thing for me regarding
the garlic street museum
is that it definitely is iconic inside
and out it's very recent
right
but if you think about it
it's certainly noticeable
and from
a visitor and a local point of view
the parking is easy and it's got a very
innovative uh interior as well
some of the museums you go in large
vaulted ceilings
uh you feel quite agoraphobic when
you're
inside
but
in
the garlic street museum you were close
to the exhibit
you were close to the culture
that was there
it's also close to the park so it's very
good for visitors
um it's somewhere to take
visitors as well
um
and they're keen to go there because
partly the tuitarium
um but also the museum itself
um
we've had a few visitors uh come and
stay with us but getting them into town
into what's there i know it's only
temporary
that's been difficult
the reason
well one of the reasons i'd like to keep
the gala street museum as it is
is it's a pyramid
and again i'm going to sound very boring
here but again this is part of our
culture whether you like it or not we
have an alphabet
and
i can remember um watching a program
about the story of the
alphabet
and
originally it came from egypt would you
believe
the hieroglyphics which means holy
writing there we are being unheard again
um the
alphabet itself
there were pictures of animals but the
sound went
and just the first letter of the sound
of the animal was used and he went right
through
to aleph which is arabic for
a
a cow an ox call it whatever you like a
bull
and then he showed
on the program how it moved to phoenicia
and then to greece and then to rome
so for me
um probably nobody else in invercargill
but for me anyway
just seeing the pyramid reminds me of
the egyptian heritage of the alphabet
itself which is a fascinating study
i hope i haven't sounded too nerdish and
i think i've done it in five minutes
speaking a little bit quicker than i uh
usually do
thank you very much a little longer than
five um it may interest you to know just
before i open it for questions that
whilst many people
recognize the pyramid as being egyptian
it's actually the shape of a traditional
maori photic yeah well there we are
cultures together
so councillors it's open for questions
i won't be nerdish with my answer i
promise
i didn't find you nerdish with your
presentation to be honest
there are none
uh i guess that's a symptom of concise
communication
uh and and engaging and interesting as
well so thank you very much for that and
thank you for taking the time to not
only make it but to come and sit in
front of us this morning we appreciate
that oh it was a pleasure
keep that museum
thank you
shall i start okay right well we used to
live here in the 70s and 80s and then we
went to the north island and when we
came back for holidays we were delighted
to see the pyramid
because we thought this was great
and i have got a question which part is
earthquake unsafe is it the
inside or the actual pyramid outside
um questions aren't really part of this
but i will tell you what's inside there
are several buildings underneath
this earthquake
the pyramid itself is a fire risk
yes
um right well i'd like to talk about the
um kelvin street
um
museum
okay
um i've made multiple visits and it's
very average
and they're just not enough displays and
it's often empty of visitors
and um before my grandchildren were
flying down from auckland i went to
visit it and i thought it hasn't got
enough for
children it's not enough
to interest a child in here
and so i think that was a waste of
ratepayers money
i think that that money shouldn't have
been spent on that because
i go in there quite often and there's
it's usually empty
it's just nothing going on in there it's
it's
it's got a few interesting things but
it's not worth the money
so um we need some indoor activities for
visitors um anderson's parks closed
bill richardson's transport world is
very good
but it is expensive it's worth the money
but it's expensive when we take our
grandchildren and when our grandchildren
visit we take them to transport world
motorcycle mecca dig this that's great
but it is expensive
and once you take the children that's it
and um
so now when they come to visit we
haven't got anywhere to take them that's
indoors
so we're pretty desperate and i think
that the um
pyramid should be
restored
um because i think it looks great
yeah that's all i have to say
i would just finish off with one comment
um
you were talking about it being a fire
risk
its actual name is to do with the greek
word for fire pyre
and when you light a broad fire it goes
up to one point so that's why a pyramid
is called a pyramid aren't i a nerd
let's hope we don't see it on fire
thank you for your submission
uh ella
joining us by zoom this time i'll just
give you a chance to to switch back on
unless she's been called oh there you go
ella welcome back
sorry we're running a little bit behind
time
no worries
um thanks for having me along today and
to give me the opportunity to present
via
conference um
so
i'll take my submission as read and just
wanted to highlight two points
um
so
i do support the preferred option for
the new building
for the museum
and just
however only um if a couple of
additional
i guess actions are carried out with
that project
and so just briefly to introduce myself
i have a phd in architecture
and
specifically focusing on sustainable
urban design and urban
and urban lifestyles so that's across
the environmental social and economic
systems and i've taught sustainable
business practices at the otago mba
program for a number of years so i have
a real interest in obviously
sustainability but in particular with
this project
for the museum around green building
and the opportunity that invercargill
has to
become a showcase for
not only our
wither in the region but also within the
country and and potentially even
internationally
so
um
i guess
i understand that the documentation that
you provided can only go to a certain
amount of detail um but had hoped to see
i guess a little more of the aspiration
of
um
what a
leadership type
building could actually look like and a
bit more of the detail around that
so the um critical success factors are
great um
i guess um i guess
following on from
the points that mobby clark was making
actually
i
am very aware of what happens in these
sorts of projects
around budget
and the potential
impact of
escalating costs
and ultimately what often happens there
is that these sorts of um aspirations
for green or or you know
innovative or providing some sort of
leadership often i do not make it and
they uh they fall off as being less
important than just getting the building
built
so
i'd really like to emphasis that
emphasize that i do support the
preferred option but only
if some of those critical success
factors are
being integrated into the project early
on
and are made true in the ultimate
outcome of that project
so
some ways of doing that i think um just
on my fourth point
and my submission is in particular to
join up to something like the green
building council
and the
green star rating program and to get an
advisor on board who
is going to ensure that these sorts of
principles are integrated into the
project
um and that that becomes part of your
aspirational vision for the project
i do fear that if not then that
aspect of the project isn't going to
make it
um sorry if that is already how it'd be
great if that's already happening it
wasn't a piece of part of the detail
that's already in the documentation i
couldn't find it anywhere in any of the
other backgrounds so um i'd love to hear
if there's already some action in that
um and just furthermore to the second
point on my list um
a number of the
well the examples for the exhibitions um
that are going to be
held within the new museum are very much
focused on the past for marihuku
um i would love to see more of those
exhibitions to be focused on also the
challenges and opportunities for the
future of our region and our city
there's some
considerable environmental challenges
that need some
community discussion they need
understanding they need education and
these are the roles of the museum
and
it would be a
real asset to the community to be able
to have a place that can delve into more
of the science
um aspects of these sorts of issues um
i do note that environment southland is
part of the partnership or had been in
the past part of the partnership with
the building of the building
um so to bring them through to the
actual exhibits to
work on how that citizen science
aspect and science communication can be
used to help our communities better
understand
um
so i'll leave it to for that um i'm
happy to answer your questions thanks
ella when you talk about um
uh
green building and sustainability um
are the
financial benefits that come from that
something that's realized more long term
or is it just
quite often perceived as an additional
cost at the outset
yeah great question so there's been some
some really good case studies globally
but also within new zealand now on the
sort of payback period for
um
[Music]
for these buildings and also
other benefits um in particular social
so um just the way that the buildings
are designed how they
encourage uh in
work um for the staff um you get a lot
more benefit of um i guess happy staff
and happy outcomes um
in terms of the actual palette i um it's
it's difficult because it's um often
over for a very long time period but
councils are really well conditioned
for that because they own the
um and um unfortunately in the
accounting processes we used to
um for our buildings don't always
clearly articulate the values for
example theory efficient energy systems
um the payback could be over
like
this example
and
they
don't always
uh
i get
there
okay thanks ella we're just having a few
buffering issues at the moment so
i waffle for long enough it might catch
up but um
councillor pottinger you had a question
yeah thank you chair um hi hello it's
ian
here
um
and i i will respect your answer on this
being a phd in architecture
now we've had
quite a bit about quite a bit of talk
about retaining the shape of the pyramid
now if we were wanting to free up as
much
resources and money as possible to to be
able to do the green
um sustainable building and put the
money into that is
building a pyramid a practical design
from your
from from being an architect
to to achieve what we want to do
or are we sacrificing
uh appearance over practicality
um
great
to me
um unfortunately not one that i uh can
say official hand and unfortunately um
as i mentioned my
phd architecture is specifically about
uniform rather
and ask you to turn your camera off
we're just having some buffering issues
and i think that if you turn your camera
off that might be of some assistance
sorry to interrupt carry on please
i'd finish with that particular question
that's a good it's a very good question
but not one that i'm um i'm um
able to answer
thank you
that's made a difference as well so
thank you for that
councillors are there any other
questions for ella
if not we appreciate your input both
professional and personal um it's a
great detailed submission and thanks for
joining us on zoom to speak to it
thanks for the opportunity best luck
thanks ella thanks
donald
welcome along come and take a seat
for those speaking feel free to take
your mask off if you can just make sure
that you've got a microphone in front of
you at the time donal i'll leave you to
introduce your team and take us through
your presentation
uh thank you on behalf of the mountain
bike club i have uh
kevin mclaughlin and marcus roy
uh our submission has asked for money to
be brought forward or made
available for a development of a car
park at the bottom of bluff hill off
pearce street
we're doing a working on a major
development for
trail trail building and walking tracks
on the hill to get people active on the
hill to be able to create a
environment for recreational and
national events
with the car park we have at the present
time we've got enough for eight cars
which creates safety issues
we have no toilets there are no toilets
on the hill people defecate on the hill
at the top of the hill and it's just
it's disgusting
it's not nice and we'd like to get and
part of our development is
a toilet block in the car park
apart from the safety issues we need
cars off off the road we need kids off
the road our membership as a club has
grown from
in two years from
148 members to 469
and just continually growing every month
so it's getting well used bluff and it's
a destination town
we've been working with the aurora
and with bme on rejuvenating the hill so
that
the wild and pines have been cut down
we're helping them with the replanting
with developing the hill back to its
neck its natural state
with the car park there's other events
that happen in bluff we know about
barrett munroe yonker junior tour tour
of southland
all these all these vehicles arrive and
bluff they've got nowhere to go they go
to the top of the hill they park on the
side of the road they just create a
nightmare for event organizers so
we're there with the car park we just
see this is helping
lots of events
we've got coming up in october
this year um the national secondary
school mountain bike champs
of which
we're expecting in excess of a thousand
entrants from all over the country
and we need
would really need a car park and would
really like to have the car park
functional for there as i start race
village for us
um in conjunction with the oyster
festival village at the bottom of the
hill
so
we
we really want to to drive the bluff uh
rejuvenate bluff help bluff and
with that it's part of our development
that's our car park concept plans uh
pump track for kids
and more trails on the hill
but we're really struggling with the car
we've got four events and we'd like to
see if we can get that board to help us
can you touch on the possibility of how
that site can be developed to
potentially
compete alongside the likes of
what exists in queenstown or rotorua
uh you said at the moment
we need to have a we need to have more
trails and we need to have more
accessible trails and we need to have
parking for people that do come
at the moment there's a lot of people do
come down and they park
pretty much wherever they can on the
sides of the streets
so what we want to do is is we have a
full development plan where we want to
build new trails
family friendly trails along with more
technical trails
to attract people
and some of those trails that we want to
do towards our neighbours which are
ocean beaches to put walking trails so
they dual use trails
thank you just
for the council of our ladies speaking
today as well queenstown and
national and international destinations
that are renowned for attracting
high volumes of tourists from from all
over the country all over the world
particularly being the southern
hemisphere when it's winter time in the
northern hemisphere
a lot of international writers do come
south looking for some time worth of
writing and we see
creating
bluff into a mountain bike destination
it would be a national destination and
also close proximity to queenstown to
also attract
um
competitors and and recreational riders
from outside of
of southland and also creates an
opportunity for the kids and bluff to
develop skills and
and and connect with the area and i just
just also just want to say big thanks to
the parks and recreation team
um steve carolyn
kate jeremy liz level winner really
supportive of this work to date and you
can't speak highly enough of their
support for the club
thanks for the feedback uh bex then
councillor pottinger
thanks i'm just wondering when um are
the finances for this project predicted
to be in the long-term plan i'm assuming
if you're asking for them to be brought
forward and does what you're planning um
align with the blast bluff tourism
master plan that the council supports
so the
the funds were identified in the 23-24
financial year i believe and we're
seeking then those funds be brought
forward to 22-23
um
at the latest ideally sooner sooner or
later but i guess once we start a
procurement process and get underway
with contracts so that some pieces will
be ready to go
as soon as we can
um in terms of the bluff
um mountain bike development plan it was
it was one of the key things with uh
love master plan
it was the most highly submitted on um
action it was the recreational precinct
um so there could be more submissions
out of any of the team precincts that
were proposed
not
so available sandy point
reasonable size car park yes
yes toilet yes so you just want that at
the bottom of pear street there
yes right thanks thank you
councillor scalp thank you through you
cheer um
thanks tim
i'm really interested in the event
creation we've talked you've talked
about in the sense of obviously in the
benefit to the city but
um and noting the there's a change in
sport and activity obviously from
traditional to to obviously we'll call
this extreme sport for one of the better
word mountain body working but you've
had a growth of 148 to 469
i'm really interested in the sense of
how many parks you actually would need
for the event
creation that you're talking about going
forward which i think that's critical
um and if someone's done some work on
that that'll be interesting to hear
um
and also the demographic of currently uh
your mountain bike people is that
demographic from the very young right
through to the older or is it a specific
target marker in the sense of who's
actually doing the mountain biking
to assist could you want to define older
well i'm not old through your chair um
no i would just like to get a broad
spectrum if someone could donald good
luck and and predictions for the future
with this board
um
our riders
range from um
that ride down and bluff anywhere from
five to
we would have some that would be in
their 70s
some of the trails especially the
downhill was more for the
teenage 20
30 year old type game person not me
but there's plenty of
what we need to to build there and what
our aim is to build more family friendly
trails
we had our first racing
at sandy point in the weekend we had 114
um entrants of that
three-quarters of them were
was a mixture of um
children and female
so we have more and more ladies that
ride down on bluff
it's a it's a wide demographic of people
it's not just young people
surprises marcus is a and cat are often
riding bluff
um
so it's a wide demographic of our club
and
a club doesn't represent the numbers of
people that ride our trails
buy a long shot so basically just the
number of extra car parks you would be
looking for
we really need what we're after is about
40
more car parks than what we've got
and by allowing that to um four events
we can have that as as a a race village
so we've got people that can congregate
and put their
uh set up for races on the car park
and then the in that car park space
and just to finish the questioning um
the standard of car park that you'll be
chasing in the center because there's
different variations of car parks
obviously what's your expectation around
the finished product
as in the parks themselves
to what standard
um we would like
we would like a sealed car park a chip
sealed car park
just because of maintenance we don't
have we don't want
maintenance costs were there with our
trail developments and with the
the way we're running the club um
as we're trying to go away from having
to maintain we'd like to build something
once and have it done right and then we
aren't reliant so much on a volunteer
base for maintenance
thank you
thank you
any further questions counselors
reverend cook
mr chair um
i just
trying to ascertain something you said
just recently
that it's not just members of your club
that are using the trails so i have a
question over the
um
conforming to the trails but
of mountain biking on the hill because i
know it's a concern and i know it's a
concern in other places that once you
establish
trails
then that's not enough for people they
want to go off and off and off and given
how much
effort
being met and those are putting into the
hill the risk that that might entail how
does your club manage that or
how does it get managed i would say not
how does your club manage it but how is
it managed uh that's a good question
because we've been talking to bmed about
that um
we we have a plan and we have an mou
with the council and and we
do
track audits regularly on our trails and
the and the way we pick them up is we
see those um what they call ghost trails
and we we generally can find out who's
been doing them we blocked them off
straight off so that they can't be
ridden
and that's just by putting logs on them
or covering them and then we go we go
and talk to the people that have done it
we don't want
once we've got our development done and
we've got
better trails than we've got there now
we don't want people with ghost trails
we've committed to bmet to help them
by where air trails go
gives them more access to the hill and
we want it to be and
we've lost the pine trees great for
mountain biking but the
um the native bush is actually nicer to
ride in so we don't want a lot of ghost
trails on the hill
and what we've done in the uh we're
doing now and in the past is we've
blocked them
we have to there's a process we have to
go through to ask for trails
and we've just done that recently to get
some more trails and
um some of them get knocked back
and that's just that's life so
we can only manage it by talking to
people and blocking off what's there
so as part of what your club does is
that educative
um process about
this is a privilege not a right don't
abuse it
be proactive about
staying on the trails absolutely we we
have what we call our stakeholders being
the council
being the ewe being the environmental
trust and the community board the rs
stakeholders down there it's a privilege
for us to use the help and
we need to make sure that that's
respected thank you
councillors that brings us to time for
this submission thanks very much to the
south and mountain bike club uh for
making a submission for coming and
joining us today we appreciate that
thank you
uh jeanette bradshaw
welcome along jeanette good morning
please have a seat yes we are running
well good afternoon
i should say our apologies that's at our
end
to the counsellors please feel free to
take your your ask off just makes a
little easier for you to be heard and
have a seat if you're welcome i will too
so i'll just repeat myself uh good
afternoon to the mayor the councillors
and all
and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um mine's about the museum
so
i haven't got too much to say but please
hear me out
um the building and the museum
uh
it didn't fall down at the earthquake we
had uh i think it was 7.1 on the richter
scale now i wasn't here at the time that
it happened i believe it was 2007 or
2008.
now that was quite a big earthquake
and
uh
it didn't fall down and it wasn't much
went wrong with it
um the engineer
i believe he made some mistakes and
saying that it wasn't structurally sound
and i've heard uh that is the case
um
why did the museum close
uh
was it really a political point
not to pay wages so the costs could be
poured into the cd the new building them
mall
that's that crosses my brother's mind in
my mind
um
now the best option i believe
and many others i've spoken to
as to let's keep the pyramid
because it's cost effective
um it's only got a 10-year compliance
for the building so after 10 years
i believe you can't do anything after
that time because of the compliance
um the history library where you
uh with the council had thought about
putting a new museum there
is way way too expensive
and
i believe
it's
been congested for car parks and way
it's very expensive
um
the third option
was the tennis court area uh next museum
or closed museum rather
it's it's far too small and once again
it's very expensive to rebuild
uh
the pyramid
is a is the best
it's cost effective it's close to
queen's
there are plenty of car parks it's a
beautiful building
it's the most practical solution
and it's a nice building
at one stage the council was talking
about extending the pyramid out to the
night observatory dome
but also i'd like to add does money
doesn't come out of the sky
most people don't have a cargo you know
they're on average wage a lot of them
there's a lot on the meat sector and the
retail sector
the inflation has gone up so much now i
mean the uh
the power the food etc the petrol
uh people can't afford to pay high rates
because that man would really go up
if there was a uh a building a new
museum put
at the tennis courts or s street
and the most practical solution and most
cost-effective solution
would be to
keep the pyramid and do what's necessary
to it
and lastly
i'm not quite sure maybe someone could
comment on this
i believe there was some work done to
the pyramid
um
[Music]
approximately 10 or 15 years ago i i
don't know if anyone could comment on
that please let me know structure
structure work to the pyramid does
anyone know about that yes pardon yes
could you please comment on that it was
an investigation there was no structural
work carried out okay okay well
uh
those are my points but i don't believe
that it's enough
the engineer got his facts wrong and i
believe it went through an earthquake
and it was still standing today
and
it's
that's those are my thoughts and thank
you very much for hearing me out thanks
janet i appreciate you um sharing them
with us it's a lot of people are shy
when it comes to um making a submission
so thank you for doing that and thank
you for coming along this morning and
sitting through the other submissions
waiting we appreciate that thanks
councillors are there any questions
if not it's a lucky escape thanks janet
really appreciate it thank you very much
for your time
louise welcome along
oops
um i'm speaking also on the museum and
i'm taking a dead office
sort of a
the the opposite stance to janette i
think
um so i just yes i want to speak on the
museum and um
and say that the public mandate
historically was for a museum in the
park
and and that ratepayers weren't
specifically questioned about the
pyramid that any that what the
passionate opinion of the ratepayers was
was for the museum at the park
they are attached in love and have
affinity for the museum in the park and
not the cbd so the council's uh
preference delivers in that
the public voice didn't specifically
voice or shout for a pyramid or the
retention of a synthetic cladding what
they spoke up in volumes for was to
retain the museum in the park the
pyramid space is ineffective
um it's got no architectural merit and
it was a fix-it job for a leaky building
that may have not actually fixed it um
so
yeah i think it failed to fix the leaks
um
and actually maybe we shouldn't do a fix
it again job again
to keep what is an older building and um
it's also likely to encounter unforeseen
problems with electrical wiring lifts
plumbing
and actually i actually was somewhere
where i got my electric blanket tested
and i shouldn't say this but like i
think
the tradesmen that might work on the
museum may perhaps say that it's a can
of worms um but also with sort of um
likely cost overrun potentiality due to
the unknown so it's not an effective use
of
public money
for what is not delivering you good uses
of space and um
anyways cost per square meter
i think i pre historically submitted for
a new build but i'm a lay person and
when i read wayne harper's submission
about the costs of per meter square ball
and yes
that's right like start afresh don't be
hampered and constricted or give free
reign to actually design what is the
best but
what is the best fit for the museum
facilities and not have to work around
and i thought is there flexibility
around
in doing a new build adjacent which i
think things were planned in parts
you've got flexibility around your
storage you have to move everything out
and pay for costs of storing stuff in
town or
i i'm not i don't know enough about that
but i imagine there's a degree of flex
of flexibility there that
you're reducing the need for off-state
site storage and the labor intense labor
to do that the bigger option
um
i actually
would uh commend you for going for that
because we it's future proof it's
thinking big we've been able to think
big for all our other community assets
this is our biggest community asset
um it's not just a museum and art
gallery it's a social amenity it's
actually the biggest social amenity in
the city in my opinion you have i've
said this like sorry there must be a
decade ago solo dabs with the kids going
to on the rainy day where do you go with
your children it's the museum and the
interlinks with the park
elderly where do you take your elderly
nine-year-old dad it's that cafe at the
museum please don't uh scrimp on a cafe
by the way don't make it too small
and definitely include a little
auditorium with sound proofing this time
anyways but yeah key social media was uh
widespread use all ages it yeah it's um
right we've done that cafe but yes
please do it well designer spacious
features of sim antarctic and tuatara
are dual cards for tourists
and i put it in here that i don't
actually see visitors the centre is
essential i'd compromise and say a good
museum of difference well done in its
own right should attract tourists as a
destination and the cbd does deserve to
benefit from the location of the visitor
center there there and i think all those
loyal to the museum
possibly could compromise and if a
central city visitor centre is in the
best interest of revitalizing the cbd
the visitor centre should be there it's
a separate function in my opinion and
probably should be d-linked from the
footprint of the museum design it's like
it's more bang for buck to spend museum
money on the museum and art gallery and
the cafe
all right i think we've done that right
the bigger version the stadium got its
hero function and i actually say that
with it like seriously
other
aspects of our community have been well
funded and people have spoken with
passion to achieve the best and when it
fell down the best and
i think i did establish because i
recalled that once 20 million had been
set aside
aions ago for a museum or art gallery
and yes when the stadium fell down and
that was 2009 2009 that 20 million did
get
flogged now whatever we call it
reallocated temporarily
because the stadium fell down but so
that's a long long time ago
anyways
um and if we anyways regional tourism
it's proven at national research
strategy level
i went to the talk by riverstone
holdings when they were going proposing
a monorail
and as part of their marketing they had
all this tourism strategy they got
regional tourism assets
um are really key but actually their
strategists in trying to support the
monorail
venture spoke of regional museums i
remember this they spoke of regional
museums as being key and actually under
um there's not enough of them in new
zealand and undervalued as a key
regional um
tourism draw card and
economic draw card
so
tourists love museums so the council's
preferred option of four thousand square
meters is bang for bucks it's not just
that
essential community infrastructure
much love multi-purpose social amenity
of the museum
it's actually an investment in tourism
and actually maybe we do have
tuatara we have sub-antarctic we sort of
do have a point of difference and we can
work on this but actually i read himself
in times mr lush's opinion and i think
yes i agree with that that it should be
a museum of vision and difference he
sees something unique and compelling
something innovative that will attract
people from all over new zealand and
tourists so do it new do it well don't
scrimp have vision and then community
funders can get on board and then like
some people go oh i'm going to miss the
pyramid out my window that's what was on
facebook and i'm going yes but can you
see the potential potentiality that
ahead when a new museum comes you go oh
wow i'm so proud of that museum can we
get like we can enthuse and excite
people for
what is a new build and actually i don't
know enough of the current design
um mr lush says it's okay but that is
right the public
in going for a new build
in a way we we probably don't need to
submit but but maybe we can be enthused
in a process to
yeah to sort of um
so that the design of it perhaps whether
it's the contents of it and the design
of it don't just do please a stock
standard architectural world do
something of difference and engage the
right people possibly
and then maybe now possibly yes there
has been i think perhaps over i've
spoken the stadium fell down in 2009 so
quite clearly the museum
and art gallery was spoken of before
that so like i am frustrated and sort of
frustrated angry at
that a whole generation
that there has been stasis and paralysis
and lack of decision
um and moles eventuated another entity's
vision
that um you know tim that your council
has rightly embraced and and there
actually hasn't been a plan called into
strategy and also
in the last year
um a hotel which is another entity's
vision
um yes we
tim i would i would actually
um i need you as mayor
like you you are
you're
you're a celebrity you put us on the mat
you're a dignitary you're liked you're
linked with the success of free fees in
your oversaw stadium and and you speak
passionately of de quiz noi sorry about
my pronunciation of pigs in a film
studios
but actually under for the last decade
or two
um you know there has been stasis and
treading of water and um
under your under your watch i i actually
need your vision and your passion for
this museum development
we don't need the fame of being put on
the map we need to tim tim for your
leadership here
and
actually in recent times i'm reading in
the newspaper and in your mirror columns
and the subjects about yourself i would
actually like you to
to get on board about the museum that
people need
um
you know yes i'm observing at meetings
and functions
um sort of
the opposite of your independence and
drive
and um
yes perhaps i'll leave it there
um in summary i commend the current
council for unanimously advocating
option two i think the bigger one was
something but but for that something to
have difference
with of both the attractions in it and
design that will attract tourists and
visitors from all over new zealand
thanks louise councillor amundsen
um
with option three uh with option two
sorry which is 75 million dollars there
is a risk around that and that is that
in our budget we have allowed for 20
million dollars of external funding
are you happy to take that risk because
it is possible that we might not be able
to get all of that funding if we go for
that option which would mean we would
have to come back to rate payers again
to increase the amount actually i am and
then this actually i i do respect this
that is right we now without this a
grand vision over the last decades we
sort of been ad hoc
that we are substantially financially
committed but i don't know that it makes
it right not to go for what
is best the best
option so i think yes we we absolutely
should and actually some sections of the
community that's right they're able to
engage
the funders i watch it happen
so like the arts or the social amenities
of the city are no less or
in priority
and um in in perhaps those funders where
they've contributed in the past
like that that is right but they they
they ought to contribute to that same
level for this amenity as has
been seen in the past
substantially i hope yes we should
thank you
because we're at time and i'm looking to
to move things on louise as always it's
a really well constructed uh submission
from you you've just dropped your mask
uh and thank you for coming along this
afternoon we
and we appreciate it
uh carolyn it is lovely to see you again
i hope that your recovery is is going
well uh tonial
excellent
yes
oh that's that's just a trap door that
you wheeled over don't worry
give me a price okay i'm karen weston
kia ora everybody i'm from representing
the
blind citizen cellphone branch and we
put in a submission i'd just like to
focus on
two
items within our submission the first
one is to do with the proposed rate
increase
in the strategic plan that was our
long-term plan it had four percent now
we noticed with inflation
and um rising costs all over the world
that
you want to have an increase of seven
percent for rate payers um our concern
is that
most of our members are blind whether
all blind or visually impaired but most
of them are on fixed incomes
and those of us who do pay rates either
through rent or through
living in a retirement village or
paying rent
uh rates through
owning a house
around fixed incomes as i said
and
we had to economize and we know that
council like everyone else is facing
inflation as well and maybe you need to
look at economizing as well you do have
assets capital assets and those
other
financial
benefits that
some of us don't have we can't go and
sell a building or
sell a forest or anything like that
unless we have access to that which none
of us
do
so i think that and our members are just
concerned that here again there's
another increase in
expenditure in our budgets and we just
don't have the month income and what's
going to what we're going to lose is
probably going to be food
and um
and and maybe going somewhere um to the
doctors or using total mobility which is
quite good at present but maybe not in
the future so we just don't know
how people our members will manage with
the rate increase the other thing i want
to talk about is
accessible buses
before the bus routes were changed we
had one of the best bus in fact i will
say it was the best bus system for
accessibility for blind people in new
zealand
that has been removed once
the
routes were changed because the announce
audio announcements on the bus became
obsolete
so um we did ask russell pearson and
nathan girl about this and were they
going to replace the audio announcements
and they said they would and they had
been working with
the
environments
otago environment council and they had a
some very technological guy up there
that was working on it
and this was last year long before i had
my accident and um we haven't heard any
more about it and we've asked our
colleagues in
otago and they haven't heard anything
about it either so if we're going to
retain accessibility
for our buses
the council needs to have a goal in your
annual plan which is a time frame of
expectation
that
the audio
announcements will be back
in the buses so blind people can access
the information properly where we are
and what we're doing and how we're
getting there
i just would like to remind council as
you are par a local body which is part
of
a government
agency that you are
um accountable to the united nations
rights on people with disabilities
and convention and i think that it's
really important that
the council does have some
way of monitoring this goal with the
chief executive ensuring that we do have
some time frames that we know when the
audio just
announcements will come back
and that we can have a very accessible
buses again and our members will feel
confident about riding buses again
um i guess most of the people will know
one of our members vic west who rides
the buses quite a lot
and um i don't know how he's managing
he's quite hearing impaired as well so
one of the important things is that we
did ask russell that we'd like to be
consulted with regards to the system
of audio just
announcements because
there are some
systems out there that are not
accessible to everybody because not
everyone owns a smartphone or know how
to use a smartphone
so
it needs to be something that everyone
can access not just those with
smartphones and we are very very
interested in keeping our partnership
with council in regards to access issues
so
i'd just like to just note that when i
came into the council building to this
meeting
there was no screen readers on the
signing in
machines and so i asked the guy down
there have they got screen readers and
audio and he said no and i said why not
because council has got that um
disability strategy and i don't know
when that's going to be look that was
supposed to be about a year ago now and
um
and so if you've got the strategy
then you should be working towards it
and if you get something new technology
we're going to say make sure the screen
reader is there supermarkets and um
you go
pack and save or countdown or any of
those places they've got screen readers
on their checkout machines if they've
got it you can put it on your sign in
machine so that was just a little bit of
an addition because i didn't know you
had to sign a machine until i got here
but i just feel that
council needs to be more accountability
for access for people with disabilities
right across the board
even just getting
out of the car into this building
tony had difficulty getting me from the
road and we had to go behind the car
my car to
get me
onto the footpath
um so he's not getting any younger
either so i just feel that uh
yeah but you needed the reminder tony
when none of us are getting any younger
so i just feel that we need to have more
access for all disabled people but
especially
let's get back to being the best city in
the
new zealand having accessible buses for
blind people and people with vision
impairment
thanks carolyn thanks for your
submission your reminders about
affordability and for raising the points
about audio description i envisage will
be able to get a written response to
that
um
back to the association councilor sopa
thanks mr chair leslie soper carolyn
um great to see you out of hospital hi
tony um carolyn
a previous submission
mentioned that he didn't believe the
rates rebate scheme was well enough
known in invercargill
do you feel that the blind citizens
community are
being made aware enough and being given
the support to be able to apply to the
scheme
um i don't even know if some of the
people would have that information i
mean i know about it
and um
i guess that's an option for people who
own their own houses but if you rent a
if you rent a um
house for example and some people do
i mean that rate
rebate scheme isn't going to help them
the landlord's going to put the rates go
up the landlord's going to put the rent
up for those people anyway so it would
help some people but i'm not sure that
information is accessible
um the info you know like council used
to have a newsletter and that used to go
on to the telephone information service
but i don't know if you have newsletter
that comes in the mail to everybody
nowadays or not
but if there's one that comes with the
rates okay so if there's a um if there's
a newsletter that comes with the rates
in print it would be good to put that on
the telephone information center because
i believe that the council still has a
menu on the telephone information center
you just need to get hold of um blind
low vision
nz which used to be blind foundation and
um they run telephone information center
you do have to pay for it these days but
i think you did anyway so yeah thanks
carolyn
reverend cook
thank you mr chair killer carolyn i'm
evelyn [ __ ] um
i have a question about you said we had
the best system was that because of the
um audio announcements so your concern
isn't with the change of roads it's with
the fact that with the change of routes
has gone that announcement system yep
okay yeah so your concerns would be
addressed by a new
um
[Music]
a new commentary yes so i don't
understand why there's such a such a
delay in having to get
a new commentary i mean eddie cook set
up the one that we had
and
he must have got that done somewhere and
we don't need to get into a new system
or anything like that there's nothing
wrong with the system we had and all
they had to do is just get it recorded
and put into the buses and speakers and
stuff and the speakers will be already
in the buses unless you've got new buses
i can't go on a bus because i don't
think tonya want to push me up our hill
but
anyway
i i'm sure that we could still have the
same system which is accessible to all i
know that some public
didn't like it and maybe the bus drivers
didn't always like it but
it didn't just help blind people it
really is beneficial if you
are a tourist and you go to a strange
city and if you have audio just
announcements and buses it really does
help you to learn your way around that
strange city because we found that in
switzerland for example we
ended up with a bus
and it had audio and we knew we didn't
we couldn't speak german or whatever
language it was but we knew by the sound
of the suburb that we were in the suburb
and we just needed to ask someone who
spoke english are we far away from that
um stop we wanted and i just said no
it's two away so it's really is handle
handy for other people not just blind
people
thank you
okay councillors uh that brings us to
the conclusion of that submission
carolyn and tony lovely to see you both
again thank you very much for for your
submission and for making the time
available to join us this afternoon
councillors you'll recall we agreed to
accommodate a um spoken submission from
nikki broad from cooper's creek uh if
you're looking for nikki's written
submission it's on board books on 3 39.
nikki thanks for coming back
well thank you for letting me out you
want to grab that seat um you'll most
well i might stand
do you want to drop your mask to make it
a little easier to hear i am a slouchy
normally so
i might keep my mask on if i can read my
writing otherwise i have to take it off
to read it with my glasses
but thank you for letting me fit in i
wasn't going to speak because i didn't
want to put the same information as
other people were doing but i realize it
spread slightly outside the area to the
draft plan itself and the license to
occupy
so there's something i'd like to bring
up because it's very important going
ahead from here and
relevant to what's the license to occupy
so please accuse if it's a wee bit
jumble because it's just seated pants at
the back of the room with one ear
listening to everything
um
so i have been a permanent residence for
over 37 years and i emphasize permanent
residence to send you
that's been known to the council and
we've had a good relationship the
council perhaps a bit uziosi in today's
terms but
we've had um i recognize the point is
that i don't recognize many faces from a
way back
um mr pottinger leslie sofer
right honourable tim shadbolt
that's really about it and the basis of
the problem is this new blood that
doesn't know the past history that we've
had with the council
and there's quite a bit that's in the
management plan
and if you read the management plan
and i certainly did um
when we got the thing we went back
through everything and it was a good
wake-up call for everybody
but there are things in there that were
not agreed to to council and after the
previous management plan but were never
changed
so i'll just get back to a few brief
notes and it might be a bit jumbled
because back of the room stuff
but there has been a continual dis this
is the basis of all the problems with
sandy point in the crips
that the parks and reserves were in
charge with under
uh mr pagan
of the management plan
for sandy point and they've done a
wonderful job it's very comprehensive
and gets even more comprehensive as time
goes on
and it's a very necessary document
but
i have to say it
mr pagan
that was his baby and he was on the
agenda he didn't want to see it that's
why it appears over and over again with
reasons
the council however when we brought it
up time after time a time
had different opinions to what was in
the management plan and we have a lot of
this in writing so that
it's not just words we have old memos
that stated very clearly
so that's the basis there
between what was historically in the
record and i.e the management plan and
what the council agreement with queen
primo is is not the same
but somehow the new management plan
would still come out without the agreed
changes being made if they'd been in
there you would realize certain things
that you won't be aware of
sorry
hard when you haven't written it neatly
entirely
the past council has heard us and taken
a vote that appreciated our value to the
area
being that we're the end of the road for
visitors and it's quite a long road if
you live out there for 37 years you've
seen people stuck on the beach you've
seen this
people with young babies stuck in the
sand at the entrance to the beach the
other entrance of the history
it's very hard now because as was said
we don't have a handle on vandalism
which is very great out there as it is
everywhere
and that is a worry to us
the other worry would be now that with
their climate change this very dry
season
you have to be aware the fire dangers
probably into the future as continue to
be very high over summer
however
and
just thinking about the end rob mcmurdo
put out three fires at wala bay that
were lit by people
that could have had serious consequences
now that's just might be small bananas
but if
the council acknowledged we were of
value
for various reasons there's a lot more
now one good thing that's come out of
this
discord that we've been having is we did
go over the management plan most of us
trying to find other things and i reread
it i've been there 37 years and i've
taken it a bit for granted i
realized that and i suddenly woken up
and i'm very pleased that some of the
things that are in that management plan
that i hadn't taken you notice of
the fact that
i always thought oe was more wayless bay
apparently oe is the crib sites
so that's a maori heritage area i think
that's really good and then your
management plan wants to put signage of
the history of sandy point round
okay unless it's set in concrete and
even then i'd
hoon would put
a tow rope around it and it would go
who's going to put if you put signage to
do with the maori villages there we can
look after it they're safe between the
houses
if you put it anywhere else
it won't be much point
we would welcome a change from the word
cooper's creek to be added
probably first are we
since that is oe
or was owen
there were things i found out because
i've looked elsewhere in library history
et cetera we've found out things like
the maori graves they might be closer
than we think they're not on the house
sites
so
we really have all woken up and decided
yes we're so lucky out here and we want
to value it and we want to add to it
now
but if i make a couple of examples to
show how the disconnect between what
we've agreed in the council and what's
come out in the management plan and what
you've based yours on which is exactly
what you're supposed to do
the biggest one would be the change from
residential sea which allowed the cribs
in the first place
to suddenly appear in the management
plan
where we didn't spot it that the zoning
had been changed to recreation
reserve so the land we sit on is no
longer residential sea which allowed
houses but reserved land now that's the
basis if we must go
you can't have occupied houses on
recreation land
okay that's fair enough
but
and excuse me if i quote you
right on them almost chapel
mr shadbolt
and one of our
came over and had a cup of tea just by
himself so he could not representing the
council but just as an individual had a
cup of tea with us at cooper's creek
and he said
i never even knew these houses were here
and the re
reason is
it counsellors and that's understandable
don't read everything that comes over
their desks they rely on the manager to
have it just right
glance through the worst you know
the main bits
and sign it off so inadvertently the
council this is acknowledged in writing
said we would never have signed it from
residential sea to recreation reserve if
we had known it was in the book
now you won't remember
mr bodinger
that there was supposed to be a working
party mr kings was this is all coming
signed off by mr kang so mr kang was
really the driver of it we will set up a
working party between the crib owners
and the council
to try and reverse it back to
residential sea
now being those easyosy time pass and it
never actually happened because we
didn't look into the future
it was like well it hasn't happened yet
we must get onto it and from both sides
obviously so that's historically it the
council
wanted us there
as residential sea now under residential
c it still says you must only have
casual occupancy
however at a later date because there's
been a few of these meetings over these
years
council acknowledged due to vandalism
if the houses were there permanent
occupancy would have to be accepted
because if they were empty they would be
vandalized
so this is a different picture to what's
in the management plan
and what i'm basically want to say is
with the management plan coming up it
needs
not one party to want to another but
three parties involved so that the
management plan when it comes out
is exactly right into the future
so they're just things for council who
know nothing about it that that
background exists
and there are things out there we all
woke up a bit and said oh this is maori
land i hadn't considered that because i
thought oh he was somewhere it was at
noki kayak or nokia corporation
right
okay let's go in there and let's take
out all the historical junk that's been
there from previous tenancies in the
bosch area lots of old iron and things
let's go in there let's let's clean it
out and that's what we've been doing
gradually well we've almost won
um
old water tanks piles of iron all sorts
of rubbish that has no
bearing on us and no and certainly
shouldn't be anywhere near maori
heritage or ecological reserve
so we're not perfect
none of us are
but and i'm i have to say just as a fine
as a i've gone right off my notes but
that's basically it
i was a posty but before that until i
took voluntary redundancy because the
hospital when the new hospital was built
i was manager for south and area health
board grounds for all of southland
i'm very familiar with management plans
both forestry native bush residences
because i covered the whole lot so i
looked at the management plan i thought
if i had this management plan
and i wanted to follow it this is what i
would do but the lacking thing is is the
consultation to put a proper management
plan into place in the first place if
that's done
you have every rule if a rule is broken
after that
fine
you have the power
but
you have to accept
that
i we have
a big vested interest itself
i'm a member of forest bird and i intend
to go into the council meeting that
they're holding with parks and reserves
this coming sunday to talk about the
development of sandy point
i since i retired two years ago i've
taken it on myself because i have
horticultural skills
to start carrying place plants with i
have sprayed both my own next door to me
had a huge patch which i rather liked
but the minute i thought about i thought
pest plants have got to go so we've i've
cleared and it's very difficult you've
got to go over and over huge areas of
aluminium plant wandering jew
and there's still an awful lot out there
but i
volunteer my services within the
residential area
to take care
you can point out things you want to go
and i know what has to go
and i will do the donkey work i'm very
happy to do that
so
that's i'll just if i've got half a
second no
i've gone way over time yes you're right
inviting me now
well that's about it because the rest of
it will come up when the management plan
but if we could settle what's on the
agenda now
bearing in mind that that licence to
occupy does not
has clauses in there that and
were certainly in the management plan
you could look at them and say yes they
have to be in there but with the past
history no they can't be in there
thank you nikki for uh for your
submission and for coming back and and
speaking to it um we appreciate that i'd
like to open it for questions but if you
want to get something to eat before your
next meeting we've got a train of three
to go
just got one question
very quick questions yes or no question
oh excellent
the question is and the answer will be
yes or no back in 1992 i found that's
when it became a reserve
was there public consultation on the
change
i believe there was newspaper it came
out in the newspaper and we had
things i'd have the paperwork's here i
can't exactly say i haven't been dealing
with it closely that
but i believe that yes it's been in the
newspaper and we had the support of say
the odata community board etc etc had
some newspaper articles saying
that that were produced
that said that council has changed its
plans on sandy point okay we're trying
to put it in a chronological order
and it's a bit hard because some of the
stuff isn't dated
and
my memory for dates and times
i can find out well sorry no no that's
okay we'll just think about deeper to
see if it was consulted or not that's
fine thanks thanks
thanks nikki i appreciate you thank you
very much you're coming back and am i
allowed to just say one thing when mr
when the right-hand wall tim shared belt
came out and had a cup of tea we had a
jolly great laugh
and i'm sure it reminded him of his
early days on a commune
thank you
thank you
counselors that brings us to the end of
uh people speaking to the submissions um
thank you for your attendance and your
attention and our sincere thanks to
those people who have made submissions
and taking the time to come along and
address us
the
deliberations were scheduled for next
tuesday i understand that may well be
delayed
so there's a suggestion that might now
be coming up on the 24th so there'll be
an adjustment to your diaries for that
i thank you and i will close the the
hearing submission
you